[Music]
one
[Laughter]
hey everybody happy friday yeah boy bye
this is
spock okay yeah he's in you're just in
the wrong place yeah look at all that
space it's not the camera
i seriously have not moved the camera i
swear to god oh you moved the chair
well yeah i might i might have moved
this way
i don't [ __ ] then go over that way
there you go you move the chair that's
right well see i don't want to go too
far over this way because then my knee
hits this bookshelf right here so that's
why i've been trying to see if you look
well i know that but
you know i can see as well as you can
that's the same thing
well no that's the same thing i used to
line it up it's just i don't i don't
want to come over too far because a lot
of times like sometimes my knee will hit
this and it'll knock [ __ ] over this way
and i'm trying to go over this way well
you can move all right you know you've
got all kind of room back there to like
fart around whatever it is you're doing
back there all right it might be that
this is insane
this might be in the wrong spot i don't
know because there's something wrong man
the control of my control panel your
control panel yeah the cabin's chair
it's not for
[Laughter]
so hey everybody
uh granthar says hey steve had another
baby or his wife did yeah yeah he has a
[ __ ] ton of them now
he had them all like in a period of
about six years
well i only knew about the one because
he came to visit us
uh that was a while back that was
several years ago and i think he had one
until we like saw pictures of it but i
don't even remember i think he's got two
or three now
his wife's young
i don't even think his wife's 40. she's
in her 30 i think her wife might be 35
or something
then uh i guess he's just gonna
have a [ __ ] ton of them before he croaks
you know before he pops his clogs
that's one of my favorite british idioms
by the way it's crazy pops is clogs
[Laughter]
oh my goodness yeah if i had some now
i'd be afraid that i wouldn't live long
enough to [ __ ] help them when they
got older
by the time they're teenagers i'd be
dead
yeah i probably unless they
cryogenically [ __ ] store me or they
[ __ ]
inject a whole bunch of nano technology
in me and [ __ ] rebuild me i mean i
can only do so much you know
[Laughter]
hormones only thank you for your service
yeah
i'm doing what i can do
to keep this shift steady for y'all
all right are you though yeah
i'm just yeah
sorry pookie's like tearing up the
[ __ ] if you hear like [ __ ] noises
uh it's been storming off and on all day
yeah we might even lose a connection
it's [ __ ] i mean hopefully it doesn't
it storms really bad earlier oh [ __ ] i
was thinking about going out tonight but
i don't think go out in this storm
yeah this is like kind of [ __ ] weather
well the thing about it is we have to go
out sunday night yeah and i don't know
if i can really afford to go out two
nights at one weekend plus i don't know
if my liver can't it's sunday or i
thought it was monday it's sunday no
it's sunday night because monday is a
holiday it's memorial day so they're
doing it sunday night they're doing
momentum sunday night instead of monday
night like they normally would you gotta
get there right
uh well the gps knows how to get there
i've been to that street before i don't
know i have to see it so i know where it
is it's john young parkway it's actually
kind of like it's not it's in like a
warehouse district i don't know where
that is so i mean i think i've been
there or around that area so it's kind
of like going to um
kind of like going to the old place like
what's it
southern nights it's like going to that
like that it's farther than that farther
than that okay yeah it's on the other
side it's actually it's still downtown
kind of but it's like on the other side
of downtown okay you know what i mean no
uh
of course you don't you know that now no
granthar said ron uh
ron what was this that ron wood ronwood
and uh mick jagger had kids in their 70s
yeah i mean i guess if you're still like
uh they got millions of dollars too
that's
pickled and formaldehyde those two
and they and they can score like 20 or
30 yeah chicks right that still have
fertile wounds yeah and
the energy to go through all that
even even when i was in my 20s i was
like i don't think i want to deal with
that [ __ ] show no for guys you know what
i mean
prime time is [ __ ] around 30.
for women i think prime time is more
like about 18 19 get it over with early
well i don't know about that because
then you don't then you can't go to
college and you because my mom had me
when she was 18 and i mean she did all
right but
you know a lot of [ __ ] gets pushed off
until later so she didn't go back to
school until later
well yeah but i'm talking about just
well yeah but you have to talk about
like people's lives too i mean biology
isn't all that matters
neither is college
no but that doesn't no but i'm just
saying that like you know that's why i
think for a lot of people it's probably
not the ideal age because it's that's
really young so
i mean i was still like a kid when i was
18. and then you get out and then you
get involved in a career and that [ __ ]
goes on for [ __ ] 20 or 30 years and
you never have the kids that's what
happens to them most of them mostly yeah
but that's the thing it's like
like i said i've never really wanted any
so it's just kind of like
a lot of people don't
overeducated [ __ ] if you're
educated it's almost like a death
sentence
in terms of when it when it comes to
having children i mean the statistics
say the more educated you are the less
children you're going to have because
you have more of an idea what a [ __ ]
headache it is yeah you don't want it to
[ __ ] well the money too and it's
always trying to you know upward
mobility and having fun you know
but that was going on even back in the
roman empire they complained about it
back then that their best people weren't
reproducing so it ended up being a damn
idiocracy just like that movie idiocracy
the dumb people were [ __ ] having all
kinds of children all the damn german
barbarians and [ __ ]
and uh just uncontrollable
and uh you know the rich people were
just dying out constantly
yeah you know just [ __ ] unstable
it don't it destabilizes
a civilization to do that but you can't
make people want to have babies that
don't want to have babies
true so
that's not true but you don't want to
incentivize not having them
which that's that's happening all
throughout the [ __ ] western world
including russia
people are just saying [ __ ] it so
they're just selecting the extinction of
their culture
just telling you the truth well the
thing about it is that i don't think
anybody's looking at it that way
everybody's looking at it from an
individual viewpoint like this is really
not for me yeah yeah i know i know
exactly but you know it's the same thing
with warfare for a lot of guys this is
really not for me but if you're under
attack by people that are trying to
extinguish your [ __ ]
country or your [ __ ] culture or your
race you better fight you know
it's not about choice you know
life is not
life is dumb you know i mean what is the
meaning of life there's no real meaning
to it what's the meaning of the life of
a cat there isn't much uh it doesn't
mean the cat's not cool just means that
they're there for a round and then they
die off and it's the same with humans
you're we're going to be here for a
while and then they will vanish are you
going down this path again already going
down that path already he started
drinking before the show yeah so he's
already going down this depressing
[ __ ] it's not depressing that yeah it
is and it's like and you went all you
went off on this ramp before it's not
depressing it's friday night i'm trying
to have a good time it is normal but
it's just kind of like we already
covered all that ground
and i really don't have the patience for
it right now so i'm just telling you
let's see what everybody's saying so i
don't really want to start on that like
[ __ ] five minutes in jesus christ
they're talking about the new top gun
um
i don't know i think waiting for i think
waiting to release that top gun was
probably the best thing i think
um they say that that new top gun is
kicking ass it's it's [ __ ] broken
records
already in it on a first thursday and a
friday
and
audio scores 99
and the [ __ ]
critic score is like 97.
they say it's a [ __ ] good movie
because there's no cg it's all [ __ ]
real jets doing tricks and [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
that's good that's good i'm just so glad
that after like i kind of feel like the
2000s and maybe like the early 2010s it
was all cgi everything yeah and then
after a while i was like man we're sick
of seeing that [ __ ] so like filmmakers
started going back toward practical
effects you saw it in horror you saw it
in other sense i'm like thank [ __ ]
christ
some people have said that this is like
tom cruise's defining movie
that this movie definitely looks okay
from the trailers we'll see it well
these people who saw it i mean there's
other there's other things that i want
to see because like i wasn't really that
big a fan of the first film but um you
know i'm sure it's good you see it's
emotional got men crying and [ __ ] in
there you know maybe the the
men in the theater crying and [ __ ] so it
must it's supposed to be good it's a
movie that makes men that's what they
said it's a movie that makes men cry why
do people get repeatedly punched in the
balls i don't [ __ ] know okay i don't
know i don't know the thing they just
say that it's a real good movie
it's which is and with a real good role
which i think is kind of
kind of impressive because top gun even
though it it's it when it came out it
was a huge hit
a lot of people liked it
a lot of people went to go see it
i remember it as an okay movie not a
[ __ ] great movie just the okay movie
i remember other tom cruise movies being
better
well yeah you know um but they say this
one's [ __ ] great everybody loves this
movie so we'll see
maybe the timing's right you know what i
mean the lack of cgi and
practical effects and real jet stunts
and the acting is supposed to be real
good so and the story's supposed to be
good so we'll see
i want to see it
murder hornet says i get a free grave
plot through the va there's space to put
what you want written on it mine's gonna
say wanna trade places yeah they give
you only so many letters yeah
that's a pretty good one i don't think
i've ever seen that one before
danny rowling says the love scenes
between tom cruise and jennifer connolly
were the only unbelievable parts of the
film yeah
uh i don't remember much about the film
i just remember thinking that it was no
that he's talking about the new one oh
the new one okay jennifer connolly
wasn't an old one oh okay
[ __ ] jennifer connolly was only like
yeah 16.
okay yeah now i'm trying to put that's a
girl from [ __ ] labyrinth yeah yeah
she's cute she's the same age as me i
think yeah maybe like a year or two
older because i remember her being like
when labyrinth came out i think she was
about the same age as me or maybe i was
like a year or two a couple years later
she was in the rocketeer her and both of
her boobs that [ __ ] she was a [ __ ]
knockout in that movie remember that i
always thought jennifer connolly was so
beautiful yeah and she
and she still looks fantastic
and like i said she's probably my age
she's probably 50 51 yeah i want to say
she still looks really good well she was
in elita battle angel and she looked
[ __ ] great in that yeah um
she was in
uh what was that [ __ ] darren
aronofsky uh movie goddammit why do i
always forget the name of that movie
it's so it's so good i'll think of it in
a second but she was also in in the 80s
she was in uh dario argento movie she
was in phenomena she was the girl that
could psychically communicate with
insects yeah so there's that been long i
don't think i've ever saw that you know
that you didn't know i don't think i saw
that one donald trump i just said i just
remembered in rocketeer she was stacked
i mean stacked i was just like whoa
[ __ ] i don't remember every guy saw
that i think i only saw the rockets here
like one time like i was like oh that
was pretty yeah i liked it but i didn't
really ever feel the need to like watch
it again well they never followed up
with a sequel it was set up for a sequel
and never did a sequel
that might be a good one to revisit
because i don't think i don't think i've
seen it since it came out or like a year
or two after it came out
i liked the shadow even though they
[ __ ] that it [ __ ] it up i don't
think i remember not liking that but
like i said that was a long time i
didn't like the bad guy i thought the
bad guy was you know the genghis khan
angle to the bad guy didn't
come on
although maybe that was from the source
material but i think it could have come
up something better than
but the way it looked i mean that movie
looked great and the acting was pretty
good in it the story was wasn't bad it
was just
the villain wasn't it wasn't good enough
i don't think
hugo says jennifer connolly is my
girlfriend since labyrinth know jennifer
connolly is my girlfriend but yeah no i
haven't no i actually really did like uh
labyrinth well like i said she was the
same age as me like right around when
that came out because how old was she
that came out at 86 right yeah she's
probably about
16 15. okay so maybe she was a year
older because i was 14
when labyrinth came out i was 14 she's
probably 14 or 15 maybe hardest uh yeah
she's also in a beautiful mind that's
right i forgot yeah she's been a [ __ ]
ton of stuff [ __ ] ton of stuff
what the [ __ ] is the name of that what
the [ __ ] is the name of that um
god damn darren aronofsky movie yeah
the one where she gets the one with the
two the two-sided dildo
and the refrigerator
you never saw it
i'm asking them i know you didn't see it
what the [ __ ] is the name of it
oh why do i forget [ __ ] like that
requiem for a dream thank you jesus
christ requiem virgin getting old it
blows try not to do it
grantham went through many bars of soap
thinking about jennifer connolly while
showering
[Laughter]
yeah i think a lot of people did her and
phoebe cates back in the 80s i kind of
feel like that was a phoebe case was
flat
i don't know like some people that saw
fast times or bridgeman high might
disagree yeah in my opinion that's flat
i saw her
[Laughter]
when i went to korea all the katusas you
know the korean army argumentation
united states are another our katusa
interpreters that were in in my unit in
our unit they were all they were all our
age you know [ __ ] early 20s they
[ __ ] loved phoebe kate's they thought
that she was the most famous woman in
the united states back in 1991
and i was like man she's yesterday's
your news we talked about but they were
just
korean guys
had a [ __ ] thing for phoebe cates
well that's okay she looked korean a lot
of people had a thing she would be she
did i think she kind of looked a little
bit korean i guess well like i said but
yeah by the time 1991 because i kind of
feel like she was really known for fast
times at raise my high because boobs and
also for being in gremlins yeah and i
feel like those where she was in like
lots of she was in gremlins too as well
she was in lots of other stuff but i
kind of feel like those were like her
big
roles that like everybody remembered by
the time 91 rolled around jlo was
[ __ ] kicking around so the [ __ ]
the introduction of [ __ ] booty had
had kinda had kind of hit the uh the
main the main stream of the [ __ ] of
the straight white male they were all of
a sudden it went from that cocor look
with the big implants to put some booty
on that girl [ __ ] black dudes showed
us that and the hispanics they're like
put a boo but i think black people
showed hispanics booty
that that was that that was something to
watch for because before that time man
the [ __ ] white girls didn't have any
ass on them nah
well kind of brother that's good brother
i mean the prevailing
the prevailing kind of look was supposed
to be i mean even going back to like the
60s because she felt like twiggy and
stuff like that like when she came along
so that's even going back to the 60s
because i feel like because i feel like
the 50s they were a little more buxom
yeah when you're talking about yeah like
a russ meyer girls i mean they had yeah
yeah yeah
big titties and big asses and thighs
that's right but i kind of feel like
when twiggy came along like ever like
everyone was you know the the prevailing
like aesthetic was more
thin although i do kind of i will say
that men's magazines at least from my
you know brief perusal of the
subject
i kind of feel like men's magazines did
have them like a little bit
heavier than what you would see like in
movies or in fashion magazines and stuff
like that i do kind of feel like women
were skinnier
in that context but if you looked at
men's bags like playboy or penthouse or
hustler or whatever they tended to be
bigger like bigger boobed and you have
bigger butts great green sparks talking
about [ __ ] jennifer colley and bowie
and bowie yeah they were both in the
same movie i mean that was like a just a
an explosion of out of something i don't
know why i used to [ __ ] with jenny
[ __ ] hard man [ __ ] up in the club
she'd be loaded and [ __ ]
and david bowie would come on they'd be
playing some david bowie songs and then
i and then i talk i start talking
[ __ ] dirty to jenny about
i know jenny wants to see me and bowie
together with bowie and them damn pants
for [ __ ] i start talking about the
pants for [ __ ] she's like yeah and
that wig you know yeah net wig because
she with it with the ball yeah yeah
come on that'd be great i'll start
[ __ ] with her you know about that you
know about and she loves that [ __ ] and
then after and then after he died i'm
like i'm never going to see that
unless someone makes a deep fake jenny's
fantasy threesome
unless someone makes a deep face yeah
i'll figure out how to do it one of
these days then you'll be sorry
i'll only deep fake that appeared was
[ __ ] um
again uh [ __ ]
dmitry
my uh dj friend from the [ __ ]
club deep faked a photograph of me and
kanye west making out and posted that up
oh that's right
i forgot about it it looked real that
was a while back yeah it was a good job
i was like what
where did that come from
when did that happen well
i got really drunk one night yeah
i don't even remember meeting kyle yeah
yeah yeah what much less flipping than
the time
yeah i don't know how he did it
he photoshopped [ __ ] photo he
photoshopped that [ __ ] it [ __ ] looked
real you've seen some of the [ __ ] that
i've photoshopped you and kanye making
out you've seen some [ __ ] i've
photoshopped you in
it looks real it did look real yeah if
you know what you're doing yeah me
hanging out with the go-go's yeah me
hanging out with folks that was my
favorite
me hanging out with andrew eldridge from
you hanging out with evil knievel me
yeah as a child i was a child
that was a good one that was a good one
[Laughter]
no i think well the go-go's one is my
second favorite my first favorite was
when i put you on the cover of teen beat
or tiger or titanic
yeah i mean
me as a kid
is a teenager as a 16 year old a 16 year
old with your with your feathered hair
hair and [ __ ] [ __ ] and i put you on
well yeah i put you on it was a real
cover yeah um i can't who was it that
was on there that i took off john stamos
or
somebody or
see thomas howell i think it was c
thomas owl uh was actually on the cover
but i actually like took him off and put
you on instagram and no one could tell
everyone thought it was real i thought
that was [ __ ] hilarious
that was like super fun green sports in
the flames like that's hot
jenny and her fantasy threesome yeah
like i said it's not gonna happen now is
it no
that wouldn't happen back then either
well
i know like like there was any
possibility that that was ever gonna
happen
i'm just deluding myself you know
but that's the thing that's the thing
about like fantasy stuff you're not
supposed to [ __ ]
it's not supposed to really happen if it
really happened it'd probably be really
disappointing oh granted bring it up
christina ricci that's another little
short busty one right here man [ __ ] i
always thought she was like super cute
yeah especially as wednesday adams i was
like i was really into her she did
another movie when she was older and she
had a white hair or blonde hair and she
was she'd gained some weight she was
she was real curvy
big boobs and [ __ ] it was a little indie
flick that she did
and um she was uh yeah she looked great
she looked great when she was i'm gonna
say in air quotes
fat
you know she said she felt fat but i i
thought she looked great
because she's short
short girls are kind of supposed to have
be curvy if you ask me
you know but uh what's the name of that
movie you know what i'm talking about i
know what one you're talking about but i
can't think of the name of it she had
blonde hair and she's wearing it yeah i
know yeah that was a little baby doll
dress yeah i know you're talking about
your little shoes and [ __ ] [ __ ] man
that was it was a good movie but i just
can't yeah i saw it i think i saw it in
the theater i remember exactly what
happened i remember she was in a bowling
alley with the dude and they were doing
stuff
there was buffalo 66. was it buffalo 66
might have been it might have been i
think i might have been let's see if i
can find a photograph of her from there
66. yeah
did i see them in the theater i might
have
yeah grampher says ray liotta passed
away yeah i was gonna mention that
actually
uh he said he jogged by grantham once in
detroit when he was here filming youth
and revolt huh and that's something yeah
it was called buffalo 66 yeah yeah yeah
that's right i saw that that was a good
movie i remember
yeah ray leota died and um
andy fletcher from depeche mode died too
i believe yeah yeah i heard yeah i think
tammy told me these um
they're getting up there in age you know
what i mean
true i mean yeah during age that [ __ ]
happens
i still feel like andy fletcher well how
old was he he would see well he's
probably in his 60s right
yeah leota is probably in his 60s no i'm
saying andy fletcher from depeche mode
how old was he
yeah yeah i saw that movie i saw that
movie
christina looked good when she was like
that
and that is absolutely not fat
um you have to see the
okay
there's a screen cap she's
she got some jiggle to her
she was super cute in that movie
she's probably about what 25 probably i
think at that time i have no idea yeah
andy fletcher was only 60. somebody said
that's what i thought i actually would
have thought that he'd be a little bit
older than that but i guess not so he
[ __ ] man eddie fletcher was only 10
years older than me
[ __ ]
well because i was like really into
depeche mode like when i was in high
school
i didn't know that they were that close
to nate that close in age same thing i
was listening to [ __ ] that's crazy me
and sophie were talking about venom the
satanic black metal band they kind of
invented black metal
and uh it's all real satanic you know
british band it's it's all theater
though it's he's
and it's it was kind of a creation of
the lead singer his name is looking
by the stage named kronos
and i always considered that guy to be
like an old guy
he's only six years older than me
yeah i mean he was like 20 he was like
20 he was like 20 years old when i was
listening to him like 20.
you know well when you're a teenager
when you're teaching and you're
listening to the music it doesn't occur
to you that the band might be like only
five or six years older than you are
yeah
so then like later on when they start
like dying off you're like holy [ __ ]
i showed them to um sophie
and she said oh yeah she's listening to
the whole album and she's like yeah this
is a good bad it's kind of like
motorhead
harder though
and uh fantastic lyrics just [ __ ]
crazy lyrics um
and uh showed them a picture and i
always
remember them being kind of like these
[ __ ] kind of fierce looking and
fierce sounding [ __ ] crazy british
dudes
and
i showed the bad photo to sophie and
their response was god those guys are
hot and [ __ ] hot bodies on there
yeah i guess so because i didn't really
look at it that way you know what i mean
like being being being a guy it didn't
really
just to me they just seemed kind of like
these [ __ ]
crazy ass satanists you know but she was
like they're [ __ ] hot
it's like yeah
i have no idea what they look like so
i'll show you i mean i'm sure i've seen
them and then i saw i went so i went
down that rabbit hole looked at
interviews with them and they're in
their 20s and they're they're funny as
[ __ ]
real charismatic they don't they're like
nothing like you would imagine that they
would be on
base just on lyrics you know and he goes
man people think that i'm [ __ ]
running around killing virgins and [ __ ]
what are you talking about he's like our
albums are like [ __ ] written or
watching the evil dead it's this is all
fantasy we're not saying this
did uh
it was it's a show
well yeah you know and the thing is i
think you know a lot of bands back then
got in trouble like especially during
the satanic panic it's like everybody
took it the people that loved it it's
the same with horror movies the people
that love them
um
it's just fun right yeah and i just kind
of feel like people that don't really
know anything about it or don't watch
them or don't enjoy them they take it
like way too seriously and they think we
take it way too seriously i'm like dude
it's just like a good time it's like
riding a roller coaster it's like woo
look at his head yeah look at the blood
spraying yeah for me
i thought it was all kind of [ __ ]
real sinister and like uh underground
and subversive and [ __ ] at the time
but then it's like
no when you looking back on it i was
like oh yeah of course they're putting
on a show
yeah
they're they're ready we're giving
people what they wanted yeah
how could they how could
how could they run a business by being
[ __ ] you know what i mean crazy-ass
satanist that's him that's what she's
talking about oh okay
yeah i see what you're saying yeah it's
just i thought it was really funny
because i was trying to get it to focus
area because they had badass album
covers and photographs in the insider
they look like like a frankfurzeta
painting of a bunch of damn satanic
barbarians coming down off a mountain to
come kill you you know
and back in [ __ ] the early 80s it was
like damn it was you know it was pretty
cool
because uh see if i can find that
photograph john smith says trouble is
with venom [ __ ] from norway and
sweden took it too seriously yeah yeah
yeah
it's like dude calm down yeah it's like
everybody's just trying to have a good
time here we're not like we're not about
that life yeah well i mean the funny
thing about it was that
i have this book i think it's still over
there actually one you know that um that
crazy like evangelical
uh exorcist slash author slash satanic
expert bob larson he's probably like oh
and he might not be alive anymore but
he's
his family like do the [ __ ] too he's a
lunatic
but
he wrote this book called uh satanism
that was all about what to look out for
for like if your kids into satanism and
it's about as hilarious as that sounds i
didn't pay for the book someone stole it
and gave it to me so you know so i
didn't give him any money um because i
was kind of worried about that
but there was like a big long thing in
there
he apparently back in the old days
remember spin magazine which was kind of
like the edgier cooler like rolling
stone
they did this big long piece where bob
larson
this like crazy lunatic like evangelical
right-wing christian person went on tour
with slayer
and the hilarious thing to me like
reading that and he writes about it in
his book too
is that he was actually shocked shocked
that the members of slayer were
surprise
regular [ __ ] dudes yeah that just
like hung out on the bus and stuff like
that he still like condemned them for
being like
satanic and [ __ ] but
he was like yeah they just go on the bus
and like you know eat fast food and like
watch horror movies and go to sleep and
talk to their wives on the phone and
[ __ ] like that like a normal person i
was like yeah imagine that that was like
82 or that was like 82 or 83 that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] cutting edge back in 82 they
got a [ __ ] skull with hair on it and
all that mustache on that yeah yeah he's
all [ __ ] excellent okay you're way at
your way up i was just trying to show
what was on the table
yeah that's this is the one i was
talking about that's like some [ __ ] off
of [ __ ] fazetta painting and [ __ ]
barbarians coming down the [ __ ] hill
they come against you cheesy cheesy [ __ ]
that was eighty-one you know
about it like remember when we a long
time ago when we did that thing where we
talked about the anvil documentary which
we always like bring up because i
[ __ ] love that
but
i don't know i kind of feel like
you look at it now and there's really
not much of a line between like the
serious like cool [ __ ] and the [ __ ] that
anvil was doing yeah exactly and it was
all pretty cheesy it was all pretty
cheesy but there's there's
there's this fine line
if you do it a certain way
it it it's cheese it's pure cheese
and that's what happened with advil
i think part of the reason why anfield
was cheese
is that they weren't in la you either
got to be in la or in england but really
the metal scene was la even the british
guys were in la pretty much yeah so they
didn't have the influence
you know i mean they weren't influen
they weren't in the scene influencing
one another and finding the
finding their niche
they were from canada they were just
watching what was happening from afar
trying to
wrap their head around what metal was
and then they're writing and performing
it at the same time and when they run
into [ __ ] guys that were famous
they'd go oh they'd start they would
work out they would dork out and start
hero worshipping on other rock stars
well the thing about them like
you know blossom yeah but they seem like
they all seem like nice dudes they
really do but
they seem to
[Music]
one they seem to take themselves way too
seriously like they didn't really have
any sense of humor about themselves
and they just seem to like earnest you
know what i mean and that's not that
that's a bad thing i don't think you
should go around like acting like you're
[ __ ] too cool or edgy for your own
good or nothing like that because that's
also annoying but
if you're just like way too earnest and
you don't really have any type of like
self-reflection or
anything like that that can also come
across as like very off-putting so you
know
uh there's that
grantham only lets his kids listen to
striper oh my god are striper even still
around
i watched this video on youtube the
other day it got recommended to me can't
imagine why but um
it was actually made by a guy who i
assuming is a christian and he has like
a christian channel where he talks about
like christian entertainment but he made
a video
called why is christian entertainment so
bad
and it was actually like pretty
insightful to see it from because
obviously like as an atheist or as like
are he than asses yeah we know why the
shit's bad but it's nice to see somebody
that actually like has the same
beliefs and the same kind of like
mindset as the people that make that
stuff
to actually like point out like what the
[ __ ] is the matter with it and to say
hey christians like make better [ __ ] you
know what i mean because there is an
audience out there for it so i thought
that was kind of interesting so he was
kind of like calling out
pure flix and david r white and all
those kind of people that
make those like terrible shitty movies
like
god's not dead and fire proof and all
that kind of crap um
[Music]
but yeah you know
uh let's see
just saw the 1990s psychological
thriller this is danny rowling uh
pacific heights oh i remember that being
really good i think i saw that in the
theater actually starring batman aka
michael keaton pretty good just saying
yeah that was the one wasn't that the
one where he was like the neighbor like
he
lived upstairs or downstairs from like
that couple and like he started like
psychologically torturing them didn't he
like put a bunch of roaches in their
apartment or something like that
or was that a different movie because i
remember like in the 90s there was a
whole there was kind of like a mini
boom in like terrible neighbor or
terrible roommate thriller movies
like hey my my roommate seems normal but
then like it turned out they were a
serial killer or something
the norse nut says tyler perry is the
only person making content that's good
that you could maybe call christian i do
kind of feel like he's
well i don't know if a lot of his stuff
is good it's passable um we've seen a
couple of his movies but
he's definitely one that's making one
making content that's more
widely accessible to people that aren't
christians because they're entertaining
in their own right i kind of feel like
the problem with a lot of christian
entertainment especially a lot of stuff
that turns up on pure flicks is that
they're essentially trying to preach to
the choir their first thing isn't to
make a good film or make an entertaining
film they want to like get a message
across and everything's sort of like
you know falls beneath that particular
goal and if you just do that then
usually your shit's not going to be any
good and i kind of feel like that's what
happened all right hold the parish of
doom said conrad lent his name was lent
i don't think it's land i think it's
lent i saw it earlier he was got him
cronic yeah what was funny is uh
uh conrad
uh had away with women
he um
was funny
and uh funny's good he was funny and um
charming
and there's uh charming is also good as
long as you're not like ted bundy no
real charming and uh
there's an interview with him and some
rock and roll interviewer chick
and she's kind of star struck by him and
he's [ __ ] macking on her and hugging
on her and throwing her over and rolling
her over and
wrestling with her her feet are up in
the air and [ __ ] and she's giggling
through the whole thing and he's
playing it for what it's worth you know
just not at all the way i imagined him
as a kid you know just
he's obviously you know he's definitely
a bad boy he's about half coked out
but he's having fun and
that girl liked him
and she was um her job was she was she
was a television
um
tv host that
dealt with rock stars you know it didn't
like a big channel it was i think
british
and she uh she loved him grandfather
says striper is playing house of blues
in orlando tomorrow night oh [ __ ] vip
meet and greet tickets are only a
hundred dollars well gosh
we should go those [ __ ] must be super
old right are they still wearing the
outfits i [ __ ] striper
are they still wearing the yellow and
black stripe i mean i i admire their um
their adherence to the theme
yeah you know what i mean
if they're if they're still doing it
holy parrish damn says there's an
infamous story about back black flag
opening for venom and rollins and
another guy gave chronos a lot of [ __ ]
and chronos wouldn't stand up to him
whatever but it's a funny story
i also heard that um chronos [ __ ]
punched [ __ ] dave raya long time ago
this is there in their early 20s they
only got into a fight with him and
punched him i don't know if that's true
either just
there's stories you know
he was jacked though man cronus was
jacked he wasn't as big as me
proportionally probably taller than me
but
for for his for his day that's
pretty big and then later when they when
he brought that band back i looked at
him and he's up there on stage at
probably about 40 and he's definitely
hitting d-ball
he's [ __ ] big look like a damn bear
retaining a lot of water got d-ball face
so he he's
he hits the sauce
somebody said they just came back and
says that i mean who is it
see somebody's been gone for a while
because we've sided with uh somebody
from the what was it the west memphis
three yeah the west memphis three and
the pookie brought him back
and my arms are huge now there he is the
norris nut he says yeah how long is that
that was a while back i don't remember
when that was put because damn tommy
arms are huge now
yeah i don't know when that was but no
i've been working on arms i mean it was
a while ago
they're going to get it bigger i'm
focusing on arms v taper soon he's gonna
be all arms you won't be able to see his
head or his legs or anything
arms and v tapers so a lot of weighted
sit-ups a lot of dead lifts try to get
the dab waist down
skinnier
um
of course uh
right chemistry too will help to help
that
holy parish of doom says there's a
youtube channel where they discuss
theology and catholicism and they made a
channel about black sabbath being the
best metal christian band
or they made a video about it yeah i
mean
that's the thing a lot of metal bands
have like christian themes in their work
it's just kind of like well it's just
kind of like we were saying before about
movies you could argue that the exorcist
is a christian horror movie
because
the christians are like the good guys
and they actually end up winning and
like defeating but it's not
really meant to push an agenda and it's
still
an entertaining movie on its own even if
you don't believe any of the [ __ ] it's
still like a masterpiece thank you he's
in england he's saying thank you
every day
no not every day you gotta have recovery
days gotta have days for growth
i actually only work a body part twice a
week each body part twice a week
um
seven sets of fifteen
to and fifteen is failure and then last
few sets you're not gonna make 15 maybe
[ __ ] 11
and just do that twice a week give
yourself time to
grow back and heal up and
but preacher pad
i think
doing arm curls on preacher pad i think
i'm using um
i have to look at what it is right now
hold on let me see
i forgot how much it weighing
yeah granters that a bunch of metal guys
are christian ozzy alice cooper half a
corn yeah a lot of them are and i think
that would like maybe some surprise some
people because people don't really think
about associating those two things but
they're actually not mutually exclusive
at all 140 140 pounds
sets of
15. six and then six
twice a week but no um
none of that satanism makes any [ __ ]
sense unless you're a christian
well yeah because if you don't believe
in god you don't need anything either
it's it's kind of like part of the total
package yeah
yes i don't believe any other thing so
to me it's just all like energy jazz
dancing all right that's why it's hard
being a satanist in a world full of
atheists it no longer makes sense
when atheists take over you know you're
going to be picking up cat litter
getting buying cat litter you're whole
hey so we're going to buy a cat litter
yeah
problem with danzig is that daddy took
this [ __ ] seriously well that's what i
mean it's just kind of like if he just
laughed it off said hey my kitty's got
to poop somewhere
because you know he's a cat dad we love
that no i think he kind of took a levee
in satanism seriously
well see that's your problem you know
we've talked about the problem that's
the problem with glen danzig that's the
problem with steven seagal that's right
you have to have a sense of humor about
yourself especially if you're in an
inherently ridiculous
kind of line of work
you know like especially if you're kind
of like hey i'm in movies where i play
like a magical martial artist
or
i make music that's all about like the
devil and [ __ ] like that
own the ridiculousness you can't like
take yourself too seriously or
everyone's just gonna like
just clown on you that's just what's
gonna happen
no um
uh 16 inch peaks yeah okay yeah he says
i love buys and tries i'm i'm 5'7 and
rock 16 inch peaks
okay yeah i don't know i haven't
measured recently
probably
i don't know
i don't know how big they are anymore
i don't have a pump on
i got i got a tape it might be 16
might be 16.
holy parish of doom also says catholic
priests love the popularity of the
exorcist i think they did i mean it
really made catholic priests look like
[ __ ] heroes yeah they were the heroes
of the movie but and they were but it's
like it wasn't obnoxious i mean it just
made sense in the context of the movie
you know what i mean i didn't i never
saw it as like a particularly religious
movie but i guess you could see it that
way because they're the heroes i just
thought
you know in the context of the movie
she's possessed by the devil so you know
you call the priest up and he fixes
everything that's just what you do i
don't believe any shit's real but i
don't believe demon possession is real
either so
you know it's just a movie
um demon possession i think is just
poltergeist
norse nut says oh yeah those movies
about the christian couple that
investigates hauntings are christian
themed i don't remember what they're
called are you talking about like the
conjuring movies are you talking about
ed and lorraine the ones that are based
on ed and lorraine warren
yeah yeah i guess you could say like
really any kind of demon possession
movie where you know the demon is the
devil is positive is real and like the
christian priest or catholic priest or
whatever like come in to defeat it then
yeah you could argue that that was
christian theme but like i said
that doesn't matter to me as much as
just make a good [ __ ] movie i don't
give a [ __ ] like what your agenda is
that's a good [ __ ] because i met
seagal once went to a concert of his bed
and he was greatly amused by my flock of
cigals shirt i have that t-shirt
yeah i got him that for yeah christmas
people laugh when i wear that [ __ ] it's
a good shirt i mean yeah
i don't know if i don't know if like
seagal had to like give his permission
for that probably not it's an idea
yeah i don't even remember where i got
it from i just bought it off like you
probably liked it or something yeah i
like that t-shirt i imagine you get a
lot of puna anywhere in that
that's probably what he said
yeah that's what he'd say and then he
grabbed your titty yeah because that's
what i would say if i was cigar
that's a fantastic shirt i bet you get a
lot of puna anywhere in that
of course because cause i'm on it of
course
you're gonna say
[Laughter]
yeah
that's a good photo of me
[Laughter]
before he weighed 500 pounds
but uh yeah
my favorite thing well my least favorite
thing about seagal which turns around
and becomes my favorite thing again
is the fact that he used to say that he
could like tell if he had breast cancer
like he would he would like try and like
can i test you for breast cancer
yeah i was just kind of like he said he
would give you [ __ ] he was the master
of shiatsu
and he could find
lumps in your breast
and
i don't know okay
like look did he really was he joking or
was he serious i don't i have no idea
but i'm just kind of like dude like
don't use lines like that come on i
gotta how [ __ ] stupid do you think
chicks are
[Laughter]
i gotta say something um because uh uh
[ __ ] bee's nest was saying didn't
didn't dance and throw bricks at
somebody no what that was
is that
at his neighbor okay no it's not what
happened what happened was is that
danzig's neighbors were complaining
that he had
a whole stack of bricks out in front of
his yard and if you see his house it's a
southern california house like
like like i grew up in when i was a kid
back in the 70s but his
those houses are old and junky looking
now look like something you find down in
long beach at carson all right
cause those kind of houses
they were built i think mostly in the
50s
and his house was he doesn't live there
anymore he moved that house was [ __ ]
junky all right a black house
of course all right
and out in front of it he had a wall a
brick
wall that went around it with [ __ ]
wrought iron gates and he had a stack of
bricks out there that must have been
about
five feet tall
it was a cube of five by five feet by
maybe eight feet by three feet you know
the stack of [ __ ] bricks
and it was there for years and years and
years and his neighbors at least one of
his neighbors started to complain like
what are you going to do with those
[ __ ] bricks get rid of those bricks
and uh they were
evident they filed something with the
city and tried to get him to [ __ ]
get rid of those bricks
they were on his property and they're
behind the wall but people got sick of
seeing them
and evidently what
glenn did is instead of getting rid of
the bricks he moved the stack of bricks
that's it you just move the stack of
bricks but you can still see him
that sets the story that seems a little
petty yeah he just moved him
but you can still see him
i mean it'd be one thing if he's like oh
you know they're an eyesore i'll put
them inside or in the garage or
something like that
or something or outback so people can't
see them right now but he's like no i'm
just gonna move him over like through
like i said how long did that take him
to do that seems like very very petty oh
very petty probably did that [ __ ] at
night too
while he's singing singing [ __ ] off a
[ __ ] dancing tube lucifuge
i just had like a really funny [ __ ]
mental image of his like big old fat ass
like outside like in his side yard like
by the garbage cans and stuff like
moving the bricks over like
very very slowly
he [ __ ] himself up he did he did a few
cycles and [ __ ] looked good for a
while and didn't back in those days they
didn't really quite know what they were
doing they didn't know how to come off
of something and
he
could keep his [ __ ] natural
testosterone [ __ ] pumping once you go
on cycle your [ __ ] hormones are gonna
be shot until you get that [ __ ] right
you'd be gonna be on hcg for about six
months but they didn't know that back
then they just thought well you go you
go on you do some steroids when you come
off you get fat that's just how it goes
no that's not how it goes there's a way
to keep that from happening
when you look at him
on tour he can't [ __ ] work out
constantly you know what i mean and he
think he just had kind of had the wrong
approach with with what it whatever it
was he took probably the other ball
probably
and no hrt [ __ ] i bet you that
[ __ ] did not have a testosterone
base was not rocking any kind of [ __ ]
pituitary stimulants he just did some
cheap ass [ __ ] debuff shot up [ __ ]
got big quick
took some pictures for lucifuge too it
lasted probably went on a couple times
later for you for three but then a few
years later man his head was [ __ ]
huge
which made me think that maybe he came
off of
steroids and went on [ __ ] hgh human
growth hormone because they thought that
was better for you back then it's not
that [ __ ] you up makes your [ __ ]
lips big and
it makes [ __ ] weird parts of you
[ __ ] grow
you can do it you could do hgh but you
have to [ __ ] know exactly what you're
doing you got to run it with a whole
bunch of other stuff and then once you
get on a stack like that you're going to
be like that for the rest of your life
you can't ever come off of that
okay
and
it's just going to change you forever is
doing that [ __ ] is kind of like these
instagram girls with all that damn boob
greed
that they'll put [ __ ] implants in
themselves where they're [ __ ] as big
as a [ __ ]
beach ball
gigantic implants that's what you're
embarking on if you're going to start
[ __ ] with that stuff to the level of
what we're talking about danzig did you
got to get on you got to stay on he
didn't really get that big i think i'm
probably bigger than him
uh now but
you have to maintain that [ __ ]
constantly
and you have to which means you gotta
get it in the gym
and i don't
hard to live a rock star's life on the
road to keep up with all that [ __ ] i
believe where you only the rock can can
afford to travel with a whole gym
wherever the rock goes a [ __ ] million
dollar gym follows him in a damn tent
with air conditioning and everything
so
he had the wrong approach he got
involved in that [ __ ] not knowing what
he was doing when you look at [ __ ]
glands
glenn danzig later
shots of him or videos of him
the shape of his head
his head is big
it's
real fleshy you haven't seen him
like a big square
no i haven't looked at him lately why
i didn't know if you see him later it's
something happened to him he looked like
a devil looks like a demon
john smith answered your question from a
long time ago uh as
about steven seagal asking you about
your shirt he said no he just laughed
and asked me where i got it yeah he did
kind of hit on my trans friend make of
that what you will
so
i kind of feel like he'll hit on anybody
probably didn't know that with a pulse
probably no that was trans he'll hit on
anybody with a ball he probably know
that girl was trans john smith also said
my other great celebrity encounter was
with william shatner oh yeah if you want
him to talk to you talk about tj hooker
he'll talk all day about that you like
that show
well i kind of feel like probably
because most people know him as captain
kirk or from his so i kind of feel like
maybe less people ask him about that
fewer people ask him about that yeah and
so he's probably like always really
excited to talk about tj hooker to talk
about that because that's probably like
a question usually i remember that show
as a kid i watched it i watched some of
the episodes i don't think i ever
watched it i vaguely wasn't heather
locklear on that was heather i don't
remember it was a cop show yeah i know
but am i remembering that wrong
i remember kind of being disappointed
that it wasn't about [ __ ] star trek
but i also think yeah this isn't space
what's going on
he's just a cop yeah there's kind of a
response to i don't know
knight rider or [ __ ] chips it was
like that well yeah there was like a lot
of cop and like detective kind of shows
going on back then but i i remembered it
being
oh good for the time good for the top
but you know what i mean i was a kid
tj hooker's not going to keep me
watching you know just it just isn't
knight rider couldn't keep me watching
i think i saw more episodes of knight
rider than i did of tj hooker although i
didn't watch it like regularly but i was
just like oh a talking car all right
uh dj maniac says a starry night has a
show by you tonight this gonna be a
quick show
where are they playing because i don't
remember hearing about that yeah i
didn't hear about that
how close are they probably not near us
maybe they're in tampa
yeah
that's kind of far this far for us
about an hour and something and then to
drive back when you're [ __ ] drunk
it's a [ __ ] nightmare
grandfather says tj hooker was fake as
[ __ ] shatner would throw his baton at
bad guys when they were running away it
never happens in real life
it's been a long time it's just like in
movies i love that i love the trope in
movies where somebody has a gun and they
shoot at the person and then they miss
and they're just like [ __ ] it and then
they throw them
[Laughter]
that always makes me laugh every single
time it happens i don't know why
uh adriana says tom who is your favorite
muscular action hero besides the rock
favorite muscular action well there's a
bunch of them what about like what about
like um well there's jason momoa no you
don't like jason momoa he's all right
now you got to go back to the classics
which would be [ __ ] arnold
and [ __ ] sylvester stallone
um the newer ones jason statham pretty
good
um
west palm beach yeah that's dude that's
far that's far yeah that's like four or
five hours from here
that's why
what does adriana ask in that yeah yeah
i said that okay
charles bronson
yeah yeah another thing is is that you
have to consider what era it is
like charles bronson
back in the day back in the 60s and the
70s
was [ __ ] pretty big
especially for his time you know they
were muscular he wasn't a big guy he was
i think average size average height
um i wouldn't surprise me if he's only
[ __ ] five seven five eight actually
but because you see him when he got
older he looked small next to people in
those old canon films before they really
cared about shot angles and [ __ ] he
didn't look that big
um
he looks like a short guy to me
but um no [ __ ]
some of that [ __ ] that he did like
[ __ ] red sun at westerns
he was
this build was similar to mine actually
i think he had a skinnier waist but
similar to mine
tj maniac says shatner ran so seagal
could hire a stunt double to walk you
want to want a drink yeah
i'm sorry i'm just never going to stop
picking on steven seagal about that
like i said he's done
honestly the next movie that he does
well the next 10 movies that he does
because he does like a [ __ ] ton that
could like direct to blu-ray or whatever
or dvd
or streaming or whatever
um
i kind of feel like
the next one is just gonna be like he's
gonna hire a stunt double to sit
you know what i mean or they're just
gonna like show his face or they're just
gonna put a picture of him in the movie
and then this movie's gonna be about
like totally different [ __ ] you know
what i mean i kind of feel like they'll
just have like a portrait of him and
it'll like be there steven skull is
starring in this and he's like in every
shot but he's just like in a picture and
then there's like other people doing
other [ __ ] that don't have anything to
do
that would be [ __ ] hilarious actually
i kind of want to make that movie when i
get sued probably but that would be like
super funny
oh my phone's ringing
uh the rock is an underrated actor says
john smith yeah i agree think about it
could you imagine lawrence olivier fist
bumping a giant gorilla
i mean
the rock i mean yeah he's no [ __ ]
you know he's not like
an award-winning actor or anything like
that but he's always like really likable
and really like natural in his roles i
think that's and that's like its own
talent in itself you know so there's
that
and let's see what else
i wanted to say the reason i called this
show
uh endless eggplants
was because you guys
planted stuff out back right
um we planted i don't even remember what
i'll be planting back there eggplants
tomatoes blah blah
we have
so many eggplants already we've lived
here what
five or six months something like that
six months seven months something like
that
we have so many [ __ ] eggplants that
we don't know what to do with them all
tom had to like
pick the ones and there's still some
like out on the vine stall but he had to
pick somebody's like well we have to use
these or because they're gonna go bad
look at all these [ __ ] eggplants i
can't believe it and so he had to make
like this big huge thing of like baba
ganoush so we have so that's what we had
like for lunch today like big piles of
that and
all the eggplants oh yeah yeah the
eggplants came in a bunch of them they
were [ __ ] great holy [ __ ] [ __ ] man
did you forget my drink or whatever
he can't remember two things at the same
time
it's like oh my god it's a list of two i
can't remember but yeah so no i
remembered it i just put it down i
forgot to pick it up on my way back in
why did my phone keep ringing because
they're calling you they love you nobody
loves me it's [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ]
um
it's
bill collectors is what it is they love
me i guess
yeah i was gonna say john smith that um
actually that occurred to me earlier
like when i called it that i was like
british people don't know what eggplants
are i'm but i mean i'm sure they know
what eggplants are but they call them
aubergines so i know that endless
aubergines you know so if you're british
aubergine
we just planted them and
there are there are so many i just i
don't i don't understand like how they
grew so quickly
there are like so many of them and
they're like so many like we don't we
don't know what to do with all of them
because the first thing tom said last
night he's like oh my god we have so
many [ __ ] eggplants i don't know
we're going to do with all these that
they all like grew already and they all
came in at the same time
and i was like well baba ganoush and
he's like yeah i'm going to make baba
ganoush but he's like we have like all
these other i don't know what we're
going to do with them so we made like
this big thing of babadoosh so we ate a
bunch of that and then like he's still
got like two big containers of it and
also
the tomatoes we have a [ __ ] ton of those
as well we've been eating tomatoes like
the last we've been putting them on
sandwiches and
everything
and then we still have a [ __ ] ton and
they're gonna go bad so tom's like i'm
he just made this gigantic pot of like
tomato sauce because like otherwise
they're just gonna [ __ ] rot we have
so many yeah so i had to make a bunch of
and the tomato sauce is really good you
didn't try it
well you gave me a spoonful earlier that
was earlier before it had um kind of
like mellow yeah i reduced it down
it never turned dark red like something
you made with tomato paste or anything
it's or it's yeah orangish
which because i guess maybe in that
tomato paste there's artificial colors
gotta be because it's just kind of an
orange but it's good but i put a cup of
parmesan cheese in it and this
if i had wine i'd put that in there but
i don't have any
it's gonna eat some of that it's gonna
be a good um
i'll probably cook it
i
i have it resting i'll go back it's
covered resting i'll go in there and
check it later
if it's still a little too soupy and
once it's cold i'll reduce a little bit
more to make up
pizza sauce out of it and then you add
water to make uh
you know i mean if you want spaghetti
sauce you can make use that also because
i have all that
raw hamburger see yeah that make good
holidays and we've been like making
because we've been trying to get rid of
it so it's like we made burgers making
burgers last night like we we had a
burger for lunch yesterday and then he's
like well i have all this beef it's like
i'm gonna i'm sick of burgers so let's
make tacos maybe beef tacos yeah for
dinner and then
we still have like
still got a bunch of it
that's much of it that big roll
and that might make good bolognese sauce
yeah that sounds good actually
granthars has some rando questions oh
boy i love him hold on let's see what
everybody's saying yeah number one any
regrettable one-night stands back in the
day granters
yes i can i can think of one i don't
wanna i don't wanna like um
i don't wanna like doxx anybody yeah
that's a problem man because then but
yeah
uh yes
yeah
yes i did have one
he's trying to get me to [ __ ] out
some of the girls that we went to high
school with yeah i don't really want to
say like who it was it wasn't that long
ago it was probably only like 12. it's
still out there and they're still on 12
or 13 years ago yeah so i don't like
want to say who it is because some
people that we know might know who it is
right and i don't really want to [ __ ] go
with that
and i don't want to help social media
you know
it wasn't a terrible experience it was
just i was dumb and i was like in a bad
mood and i was kind of like drunk and
went home to somebody i probably
shouldn't have like under different
circumstances i wouldn't have but you
know what i mean so yeah i'm not going
to say who it is though but yes i do
have that but that's kind of like i
think that's kind of the only one
because honestly the only other times
i've done that the only other time i've
done that like just like met somebody at
a club and it was like okay and like did
that like i actually ended up kind of
dating that guy for like a month or so
so it wasn't like just a one-night stand
like it you know it was more than once
but this one time
that was the only time that it was like
really one and i was like holy crap why
the [ __ ] did i even do that like even
like the next morning i was like oh my
god i don't even want to talk about this
yeah we're uh i didn't realize maniac
was in there bro how long have you been
in there maniac
when he said he had to go because he's
going to a party okay yeah i don't know
if he's gone now somebody was asking
about yeah i've got another party to
head out to in about an hour this is the
fourth one this week yeah you were
saying earlier that you had and he told
me earlier he messaged me and said
because we were talking about gwar yeah
on uh you know the last show and he was
saying that uh he knew like most of the
members of gwar yeah he's like pretty
much there's only one
uh original member but he's like under a
different name now yeah he's playing a
different character hornet's saying that
i heard stallone was short yeah
yeah he's
he's a little bit taller than me but
he's not wrong with that no this is what
he's he's abandoned weight i'm short too
yeah
that's one of the good things if you
want to put on
size and shape
being short is a [ __ ] huge advantage
because everybody
loses fat and gains muscle at the same
rate
pretty much no matter how
tall you are so it takes a lot longer
for a taller skeleton to fill
out once a taller skeleton is filled out
it looks good okay
you got to look at go back to the
classics all right and that would be
arnold schwarzenegger and his [ __ ]
and his [ __ ] buddy um what's his
buddy from sardinia
oh [ __ ]
franco colombo
okay
arnold was six something franco was
shorter than me i think he was five foot
four
and frank goes in and he's in uh conan
one he plays the scout that looks and
sees the village before the [ __ ]
horses come and kill everybody they had
him with a red wig on
but you can just look up franco colombo
and [ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger
standing next to each other and look for
the [ __ ] photos when they were in
their prime
they both look [ __ ] great all right
franco's physique would take would take
less time to fill out
and he was stronger franco was stronger
than arnold
arnold will tell you that
especially in strong man competition
franco could pick up a [ __ ] old
school 70s refrigerator and run with it
and do all kinds of stuff and there's
all kinds of heart interviews with
arnold talking about how franco was a
sub-human he was like a monkey he could
hang by his feet he could do all this
and it's because it's all that muscle on
a short skeleton
allows for a lot of
leverage it takes a long time
for a tall guy to catch up with the
short guy eventually when that tall guy
is fully stacked he will be stronger
at certain events
like bench press bench press
for a tall guy he's got to extend his
arms if he's got long arms that's a lot
longer distance than a short guy with me
that's what [ __ ]
20 inches maybe
you know so there's less energy for me
to to bench press something a tall guy's
got a bench he's got to move it a lot
further
and
the the leverage isn't the same it's a
long skeleton so it takes a long time
for them to build up a bunch of muscle
on it but once a tall guy is [ __ ]
totally stacked yeah he gets very strong
but there's going to be
once each frame is maxed out a short guy
is going to have certain strengths
and weaknesses and uh a tall guy is
going to have certain strengths and
weaknesses and they're they're different
but there have been a whole debates on
that whole videos made between
bodybuilders and what's better
but when it comes to just competition on
stage
if you factor in time how long it takes
to build it sure guys have an advantage
it just they fill out faster
graspers also has another question uh
what how is the best way to eat for five
dollars a day
i was like watching a bunch of these
types of videos where people were eating
for five dollars a day or they would go
and buy like a week's worth of groceries
like three meals a day for however much
and it worked out to like five dollars a
day or a dollar a meal or whatever
usually what they would get
they eat a lot of mexican mexican style
food
um rice and beans was a big thing that
they because you can get a lot of that
for like not very much
um eggs
a lot of that kind of stuff
getting stuff like um
flour because you can make your own
bread and you can make your own noodles
and you can make your own like with not
very much stuff but i kind of feel like
mostly
you know and you can get like a whole
bunch of like tortillas for not that
much money too so a lot of what they
would do is they would make
mexican style food like with beans and
rice or they would make like breakfast
burritos or something like that and it
ended up like being like super super
cheap okay um murder horn it says ew
eggplant no it's good to do with it i
didn't used to like eggplant but if you
cook it right it's actually like really
good it's good for certain dishes uh
john smith says rock is an underrated
actor think about it could you imagine
lawrence oliver fist bumping olivier
olivier lawrence olivia i already read
that okay yeah
yeah rock the rock is he's a good actor
real good uh i think the best work i
think is that he he did was um in um
[ __ ] um
painting game he did a real good job in
paying a game because he played against
character type and he did a good job he
played a [ __ ] bible thumper
in a comedic way a muscle builder bible
thumper he did a real good job in it
um well and he played him like funny but
not like making fun no he played like it
was it was comedic but he was playing it
straight though he wasn't like making
fun of the characters yeah
um adriana said
bronson had russian descent didn't no he
was lithuanian
the russian guy you're thinking about i
think is uh
yule brenner
yo brenner was part mongolian
which and i think that might have been
from
i think his family might have been
russian but uh racially i think it's
part mongolian remember but uh no um
lithuania is where uh if i remember
correctly i'm pretty sure it didn't
sound right
i think it was lithuanian i mean you
know yeah i don't know i don't know
i think it was
yeah
tammy's asking us to help her name her
new puppy
um
he's black and white with a little brown
he's a mutt probably part beagle
and part something else horn i said
bronson's wife was a cutie you know
exactly you're talking about yeah
the wife back in this jill ireland jill
ireland
well they were married a long time they
were in a bunch of movies together like
later on too yeah she died of cancer
like before yeah back in the 60s man in
the 70s they when they were both [ __ ]
at their at their peak they looked
[ __ ] great together
danny rowling said i heard stallone used
to stunt [ __ ] and his infamous adult
yeah he did he's got a porn movie out
there it's called the italian stallion
yeah he's not jack then though he didn't
get jack till later but he probably just
said that because it wasn't very big
uh no i know if i remember correctly i
haven't seen it so i mean i've seen like
clips from it but i've never seen like
any of the like the money shots no
there's not i don't uh there's been
nothing negative coming out of that
movie uh i don't i don't remember
anything unusual but i haven't seen that
in a long time no i think he was
pretty well endowed if i remember
correctly
although maybe it would be good to like
cover your bases like either way i said
oh that's not my dick
you know what i mean because he's famous
now so i did either way he admitted to
it like whether it was too small or
whether it was big or whatever it's
probably like better to say like no that
wasn't me
no he admitted now that you're famous he
admitted that that was him
no everybody knows it's him they're
talking about whether it's his dick or
not it's obviously his dick from what i
remember correctly but like i said i
haven't seen that movie like i haven't
seen the whole thing why would i sit
through the whole thing
you know what i mean i've seen like
little like stills from it and like
clips from it but i've never seen the
whole thing it's just a regular 70s porn
movie
yeah there's nothing really unusual
about it and i don't remember anything
unusual about
him in a negative way
like remember
we kind of watched that as a gag back in
the 80s no i thought it was yeah i don't
really remember much about it but you
know
lars ulrich says david prowse darth
vader had a really impressive physique
yeah he was a big [ __ ] yeah and
murder hornet said wasn't he in
clockwork orange yes he was he's a
muscle man he was like the he was like
the the house boy guy that was like the
bodyguard for the guy in the wheelchair
yeah that yeah that was him he was in
other movies too like and and i kind of
feel like maybe people don't recognize
him because he wasn't in
costume you know because when he was
just him but yeah he's been a lot of
movies yeah he's a big dude
yeah that's right because that was like
it wasn't called italian stallion at
first was it yeah dj maniac said no
italian stallion was the re-release
title after he got popular with rocky
original title was party at kitty and
studs yeah
why do i know that
you know i asked myself that question
every single goddamn day that's charlie
and jill ireland back in the day i mean
that that's a that's a great couple
great couple
look at her midriff she's got the
[ __ ] midriff in the little [ __ ]
70s 60s sandals hippie stuff i guess
would you say 60s or 70s i have no idea
good job
[Laughter]
what are you doing moving you out of the
way so i can get it
you dropping [ __ ] all over my feet
trying to remember what you're trying to
see what year that was that's got to be
60s
hugo says i know doom is not a great
movie but the rock was good in it he
plays a bad guy
i didn't realize he was in that
they made wait they made a movie out of
doom like the video game yeah yeah it
was terrible but this rock was good in
it yeah most movies made from video
games yeah yeah
you would think that they would have
learned by now but they never do no i
think the only ones that little kids
kind of go to see it i guess
yeah
hey that's a good question was like a
video game movie that was actually
decent
none
no
i'm drunk oh sonic
sonic the hedgehog remember that was
well it was that was good i don't know
yeah it was okay i like sonic
silent hill was okay
for like the silent hill but the thing
about it is that silent hill the game
was all was already like kind of creepy
and already like a horror movie so it
like lent itself more if you take a
video game like doom which is just
essentially like a first person shooter
with no plot or anything really although
it might have developed a plot later on
i don't really know media says she has
hips hips didn't exist on women in the
70s because cocaine yeah yeah right
i think that might have been from the
60s that picture late 60s probably
but i can't i mean i'm sure there's got
to be more than that
they were based on video games that were
good and i'm not talking about like so
bad it's good oh speaking of which so
bad it's good you guys
if any of you guys are like into mst or
rifftrax or anything like that rifftrax
they have um
their own youtube channel obviously
and they will post
shorts they will post like free movies
and stuff like that with the riffs on
them and the one that they just posted
yesterday or the day before i just
watched it last night holy [ __ ] i didn't
even know this movie existed i don't
know what year it's from
it's called
to catch a yeti
and meatloaf is in it
yeah and the conceit of the film
is that meatloaf is like a
a yeti hunter or some kind of
unusual like a cryptozoologist under or
something like that
the conceit of the film is that a yeti
isn't actually like a big huge like
scary abominable snowman type of thing
but an adorable
mac and me type of like animatronic
creature that's very small but has just
big-ass feet
and then there's like a cute kid becomes
involved it's just like
what a [ __ ] show
but
where did they find this [ __ ] man i
don't know man where do they find this
[ __ ] there are movies that are made that
should have never been made and they've
just kind of surfaced and you look at it
you know like that dude it seems like
it's it's like going into like a sewer
pit it's like you feel like oh okay
here's like the first seven layers of
[ __ ] and you think you've got to the
bottom there's no bottom
you just keep going down it's like
there's just worse and worse movies you
keep like coming up with new ones now
there there's there's a bottom i know
the bottom
if you get so bad that it's no longer a
movie and it's unwatchable those don't
count
it has to be a movie when it's done
and it is something that has dialogue
and a story and it and you know what i
mean and it was it was shot okay
it had actors in it okay we pointed a
camera and [ __ ] right
yeah and here it is things ensued the
worst movies are that dude who [ __ ]
he is always starring in every one of
them and he's some genius from another
planet constantly what's that dude's
name oh right um black guy
hold on [ __ ] cinema has done like a lot
of that's what's that dude's name he
funds his own movies
right writes them neil breen neograd
green brain green with a b
neil breen yeah the worst that is the
rock
bottom those are cringes
holy [ __ ] they're cringe i almost wanted
wanted to get collect them all that's
how bad they were don't do that i mean
unless you like steal them off the back
of it i wanna don't pay for i actually
wanna don't get that dude money don't
encourage him i'm on cd don't encourage
me all the neobreed [ __ ] that's how bad
they are they're terrible
too
terrible and each one he's always the
star in every one of them and he always
has like super magical powers super
magical thing some magical guru yeah he
can always more intelligent than
everybody else he's solving the world's
problems he's from another planet he's
more advanced he can do everything on a
computer he's got spiritual powers
i mean everything he's always like an
alien or you can like engineer you can
kind of like glean a lot from his from
about his psychology way from the movies
yeah and there's always some girl who's
like in her 20s who's [ __ ] it's the
hottest girl he can get to star in the
movie that's she's in it and she
constantly follows him around and is
impressed by everything that he does
and then and then she loves dudes like
that i kind of feel like that's their
ultimate fantasy that's the movie they
want a hot girl that will just not have
any like life or personality
she's just hot but she'll just like
follow him around
everything you do is just like oh my god
everything you do makes me wet it's like
everything yeah yeah that's
that's like that's like that type of
dude's fantasies you are saving the
world you're so superior you're normal
human beings you're so awesome you're so
much better than ever you're so much
better than me yeah yeah exactly exactly
everything you do is awesome i have no
thoughts of my own or life of my own
yeah yeah it's only you my whole life
revolves around you yeah yeah yeah yeah
i kind of feel like dudes like that like
have that fantasy go ahead they make
little [ __ ] they make whole movies about
it yeah neil breen neil breen it's
b-r-e-e-n i think
b-r-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-f
neo brain he's made a [ __ ] ton of movies
yeah which is more than i've ever done
and he funds them himself fair enough
yeah it's just his little projects
they're rock bottom productions but they
are getting done they are movies they're
movies they're just not any good
movies
[Laughter]
they're uh
i'd say technically
better than birdemic
but i don't really consider bredemic to
be a movie although burdemic is a laugh
[ __ ] right that's [ __ ] terrible
that guy yeah that guy that made
birdemic what's his name
he's a vietnamese fellow yeah he doesn't
understand how how white people date
well he doesn't understand how humans do
anything ever right i think he might be
legit from another player he's like
his
or uh you know that particular guy the
dude who did redemic his whole
his whole [ __ ] understanding of the
way caucasians date is a man sits is
that the white guy sits
on a [ __ ] chair
and the girl sits on his lap [ __ ]
cross a [ __ ] and straddles him
that they sit on each other and they
don't move and then they just sit on
each other's lap every time he's always
got some cutie in there and some white
dude in there she always sits on his lap
and just sits on his lap that's dating
sitting on laps
that's a relationship sitting on our
laps
it's just that's his
well for the western audience we're
going to do this that's that's weird
well and you have to think like too
burdemic that's what impressed him
he did another movie called replicas
which rifftrax also did a version of
which is
hysterical which is kind of like a weird
like sci-fi movie like about cloning
kind of yeah which is similar to but
it's not quite as fun but it's still
like pretty what the [ __ ] and it's still
like pretty entertaining
but his whole thing like he seems to
equate and like i said a lot of these
movies
you can see like what the dude's
psychology is yeah from the movies that
he makes because a lot of the things
that he equates with dating are
essentially stalking yeah like if it
happened in real life i forgot about
that you would mace that dude yeah
okay or you would like call the cops or
get a restraining order
against that dude this is that's not
romantic it's not his idea of dating and
the way white people meet each other
is that there's a white guy who's just
walking around
okay he walks around and looks at things
and a girl comes walking by and he sees
her and follows her home look at that
object i'd like to possess and then then
she goes into the house and he comes up
and rings the door up and goes i
couldn't help but notice you four miles
back
i love you
you're very attractive
can i come into your house
just
and she's like sure
yeah
that's why i'm saying i think that dude
might legit be like an alien in a skin
suit yeah because like what on what
planet
that's how he's imagining it
like in
in reality
that story would turn up on reddit yeah
as like a horror story if you followed a
girl home for any of you foreigners oh
my god i had an american girl home and
say i just saw you
downtown she was gonna [ __ ] shoot you
you were getting shot she will [ __ ]
shoot you
she'll go in and come back with a
[ __ ] shotgun
i don't care blam yeah
yeah [ __ ] i mean pretty much
yeah who does that
a serial killer that's not the only
person yeah that's what i'm saying a
serial killer or a serial rapper you're
not paranoid right dudes are creepy like
that's creepy you don't follow a girl
home that you don't creep yeah yeah
crazy i don't know and i kind of feel
like they're well okay the weird thing
about this and i this is why i never
liked
rom-coms or things like that like even
going back like decades because there's
a trope in rom-coms
that you know not so much anymore
thankfully i don't think they do it as
much anymore because they know that it's
a problematic um is that
dudes it's like women are oh we're so
hard to get and blah blah and you just
have to be like persistent
so i kind of feel like dudes of a
certain generation have sort of like
internalized that message it's like well
if she says no or she seems like
reluctant at first then i just have to
keep trying
so they'll kind of like at which point a
woman nowadays will be like please get
away from me or i'm going to have you
know i'm going to call the cops and then
they get mad but i'm just like that's
creepy behavior we don't i don't know
you
like what are you doing like you're
acting like yeah it's super creepy it's
super creepy nobody likes that whole
persistent thing nobody like it's just
creepy
that's all
creepy south american culture it exists
but they're playing a game when that
happens
and
you can't
it doesn't work up north you know what i
mean like
and and i think that's probably out of
style even now probably in south america
in brazil if a girl liked you she would
constantly
be around you
you know what i mean and she'd be
talking loud to try to get your
attention to get you to look at her well
i kind of feel like even in america if
you know what to look for yeah let me
finish
so then you go hey how you doing and
they then they pretend then they start
playing hard to get
yeah
and then if you stop pursuing them or
stop showing interest then they get mad
and storm off
and that's a that's a south and central
american thing is that and it has to do
with catholicism okay
they want to go out with and in brazil
the women were more the aggressors than
the guys
the woman cannot
have the responsibility of picking up
another dude you have to be or picking
up a dude you have to pick her up
therefore she can't be blamed in the
confession booth
you understand what i'm talking about
yeah
so there they bait you into being the
aggressor and if you're not the
aggressor
she's gonna get mad but the thing is
though is that you are not choosing her
she's choosing you it's just that you
have to understand the cultural subtext
okay
now sometimes those guys would come move
up north and expect that game to be
played
but it's not being played sometimes in
their mind their imagination they think
that the girls are playing that game
with them but it's not that's a south
american that's a brazilian thing an
argentine thing probably mexico see
that's from mexicans that's your
imagination you're right
probably the same way in mexico i don't
know i have to ask come when he shows up
most of the time i'm we're not even
noticing europe yeah so but the thing is
though is even in central and south
america that girl has
chosen you
she has chosen choosing you to be the
aggressor
and and to pursuer
okay it is not it is not western liberal
democracy thinking okay it's it's it's
south and central american thinking
so the the aggression in it actually is
the female not the male
in brazil when i was there in the 80s
growing up
to respond to a woman's advances was a
sign of weakness
so you had women that were trying to
bait you in
at least with me you know as a teenager
they were trying to beat you into
conversations and bait get attention and
then there were
three or four of them all competing to
try to get to try to get your attention
and if you gave in to them that was a
sign of weakness you're supposed to be
aloof and hard to get
and the harder you were to get the more
they would double down and triple down
on trying to get it was ridiculous
but these were teenagers okay
you know it was a teenagers
um
but evidently according to everybody
else
growing up there all my brazilian
friends that that's the way it went all
the way into the 20s in your 20s in that
generation back then so it's not the
same game
um could be
when you have immigration in the united
states especially south of south and
central america middle east
from their point of view an american
woman is [ __ ] sending a lot of mixed
signals to them
so they don't get it they don't
understand they don't understand the
northern ways
um
religion has a lot to do with it
uh catholicism and islam
similar in certain ways
but
north america is
if you go back in time it's mostly
um
puritanism in the northeast
and um
again protestantism in the south
and it's a different scene you know the
the the morality is different
the
the tenets of liberal democracy if you
go back far enough
this comes from the northeast is
puritanism no matter what they say it's
puritanism
uh
well and the thing about it too is that
women are absolutely sending signals
here too it's just that sometimes maybe
they're more subtle or maybe and if
you're paying attention you can see them
yeah the thing about it is that
if a woman wants you to approach her
you'll pretty much be able to tell that
if you are astute enough to see that
like i said sometimes it's you know
subtle they don't want to be like too
[ __ ] thing but
the problem is that a lot of dudes think
that everything's going to be super
obvious so they'll come up to a woman
and she'll be sending obvious signals
that she doesn't want you there like
she'll be kind of like turning away from
you or just giving you like monosyllabic
answers or whatever and like some dudes
keep persisting keep persisting keep
persisting and i'm like dude that woman
is telling you she does not want to talk
to you obviously she's turning away from
you she's not really answering she's
doing this kind of [ __ ] like take the
[ __ ] hint but most people don't so
there's that they just keep like
doubling down on it which like i said at
that point you become like a creepy
person that has to have the bouncer
called on them but there's that
holy parish of doom says that's an
observation from uh one of the old mst
crew that it seems that most men who
make movies have major issues with women
yeah yeah they do yeah they do in sales
a lot of them they do
nerds a lot of them that never got any
attention and i mean it's you know i
yeah i love movies uh you know and i
like a lot of male directors but and i
mean most of the ones i have i why i
like or like don't have that problem but
yeah i can see like what they're talking
about some of them like absolutely do
have some like yeah big issues that
they're like working out
adrian it says lucio fulche had great
films and others that were just
unwatchable yet i like them all i kind
of did too i mean he had some shitty
ones he made so many movies
but one of my favorite ones you've
probably seen it is uh the psychic
that's and i feel like that's when a lot
of people don't talk about but i really
really liked that it was kind of like a
giallo movie but had like some psychic
like paranormal sort of aspects to it
but yeah i really dug that one we
probably need to like review it at some
point i don't know why we haven't
um let's see
every rom-com should be called trying to
[ __ ] yeah pretty much
trying to [ __ ] trying to get [ __ ]
yeah serpent surfer says richard layman
wrote better relationships
i hope you're being sarcastic but yeah
and that dj made it i said that too the
[ __ ] ellie did richard look i love
richard layman but if you're i mean okay
he's really good um he's a horror author
by the way he's passed away he passed
away a long time ago
if you're into like splatterpunk stuff
and you just want something that's like
fun and like super gory and super
violent and super smutty
then
yeah but richard layman um
wrote like an over
testosterone teenage boy
about everything
um you just don't understand i mean
if you know that going in
then they're just like a good time but
some of the stuff that he writes i'm
reading it going holy [ __ ] really dude
okay but um
it's like it's a lot i kind of like i
remembered reviewing i reviewed a couple
of his books on my channel
i did come out tonight and i did
body rides which was
that was crazy
all these books are kind of crazy i
haven't read like a bunch of them but i
read like maybe five or six of them body
rides was um with something else but
okay let me give you an example
one of his books come out tonight which
is one that i reviewed like a while back
it was about this woman
and she's she just got a new boyfriend
and they've decided they're gonna have
sex for the first time
and they don't like he doesn't have a
condoms or his kind of breaks or
something like that so he's like well
[ __ ] i gotta go to the like store and
get more condoms so he drives to the
convenience store like two blocks away
right and he doesn't come back so the
girl is just kind of like well what the
[ __ ] should i do and she like [ __ ]
hems and hauls for like an hour and a
half and i'm just sitting there like
girl do something like whatever like or
don't do anything like what's the
[ __ ] difference who cares but she
decides that she's gonna go this is la
like in some sketchy ass neighborhood oh
i'm gonna like walk out walk down this
convenience store in the sketchy ass
neighborhood like the middle of the
night and see what happened to my
boyfriend so she goes down there and she
can't find him and then like she ends up
getting picked up by this teenage kid
that she kind of knows because she's
like a substitute teacher the kid turns
out to be a psychopath who rapes her
multiple times like in horrible ways and
then like leaves her for dead and dumps
her off an overpass now that's not like
even the worst thing that happens to her
the two teenage boys who find her this
is literally this is in the book you
guys i did not make this up
so they think she's dead because she's
like laying at the bottom that she's
naked she's like she's obviously been
like beat up and [ __ ] up and
everything like that she's laying at the
bottom of the overpass and the two
teenage boys like come up to her and
they're like whoa we think she's dead
literally the first thing that these
teenage boys think of in the book
let's turn her over so we can see her
tits
and then they were like maybe we should
stick her fingers stick our fingers up
or snatch [ __ ] like that and i was just
like please tell me that teenage boys
don't think like this because that's
horrifying
but yeah so that's like the first thing
they think and then oh [ __ ] she's alive
and then there's this whole thing i
don't know like i wrote this whole thing
about it i did a review and i talked
about it on there but it's just kind of
like
that's kind of like what you're getting
into with the original i like the books
they're entertaining
but the way he writes female characters
is
horrific and also like kind of hilarious
like from a woman's point of view like
if you read it it's like just it's it's
just an endless source of like hilarity
for me because it's like so so funny
because i'm like obviously
i'm like did you not know
like i did no woman ever has ever
thought this or anything like that but
it's like it's cool it's funny that you
think that but yeah so but they that's
why they're funny to me i just find them
like really entertaining for that reason
just because
just because i can't believe that
anybody would think but i just i just
think that he wrote them as like
weird adolescent fantasies basically and
obviously there wasn't there's an
audience for that like [ __ ] i read them
i think they're funny but
i think they're funny and
you know if you like really gory [ __ ]
like really
he kind of gets like lumped together
with
sort of your splatter punk authors like
from the 90s particularly like jack
ketchum and douglas clegg and people
like that um edward lee
um he wasn't as good a writer as them
but
um it's the same kind of thing so it's
like everything so if you just want
something that's like really sleazy and
like just really like super gory and
like over the top and like kind of
stupid
um then yeah you could certainly do a
lot worse but you know there's he's
famous for a reason but some of his
stuff is like so
what the [ __ ] that you just like can't
believe that like somebody
that somebody wrote that
i don't know i just find them very funny
but john smith said that's the kind of
stuff pickup artists teach to in cells
yeah well like what is what i was saying
before about being like persistent like
if women are like giving you signals
like that they don't want them to talk
to you like to keep at it i was like
absolutely don't don't do that you're
not going to be able to overcome
resistance don't do that well and the
reason about it like the the only reason
that women don't just like look right in
your face and say hey [ __ ] [ __ ] off um
i mean i will but i'm an [ __ ] yeah
but a lot of women won't because you're
kind of socialized to
not cause a scene not cause conflict
you're always supposed to be like polite
you're always supposed to be nice and
you feel bad like hurting other people's
feelings
but you know once you get to my age and
you don't really give a [ __ ] about
anybody's feelings anymore so it's like
you'll just tell people look [ __ ] off or
i'm gonna punch you but when you're
young you don't think like that you're
always kind of like trying to be like oh
well i want people to like me and i
don't want to be me and blah blah and so
you'll kind of try to be nice to that
person even though you would really
really want them to go away
in general you're not going to be able
to overcome resistance
if a woman is resisting you it's because
you're not attractive
shouldn't like you
good that's just it you're not gonna be
able to overcome yeah and i mean and i
mean pursuing that further is just gonna
make her like you less yep because
they're like you're just getting
creepier because the time goes on and
it's getting to a point where we're
gonna have to call somebody yeah usually
what it is is it's something you're ugly
what does she want to do with you two
she's thinks you're a [ __ ] creep all
right because one there isn't a woman
with you already
uh you're being aggressive
uh which uh you're just trying she knows
you're just trying to get laid and then
you're gonna move on all right uh she it
doesn't matter how good looking you are
no it really really doesn't women don't
care about that
she she doesn't know you all right
i had a lot of
success with women but that's because
they knew me by the way thank you zach
what's it what do you say
you mean you've never stood outside your
crush's house holding up a boot box
playing at power ballot standards at
midnight of the pouring range and i have
not
yeah
i've never had i never had to overcome
any kind of resistance because there was
never resistance
all right they already knew me they were
already up for it
okay
and that's because
what man i don't want to sound like a
[ __ ] pickup artist is that because
she likes you already
there's no resistance well the thing
that women find i think one of the
things and i'm not speaking for all
women obviously because everybody's
different yeah but i think one thing
that turns women off
is
male
goal oriented behavior yeah i'm gonna go
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that's they see that
[ __ ] a mile away
i'm a man and i can all think y'all
being slick
you're not being sick
no not at all and a woman can
immediately see hey this dude just like
thinks i'm hot or thinks i'm cute or
whatever
and they're just coming over like
pretending to be interested in you so
they can get laid yeah and women just
really don't like that no and because
they can see that like dudes think
they're being slide everything like that
we're like oh jesus christ here it comes
they can see it before you even come
over there they can see it in your body
language they can they see it so you
come over there and try that [ __ ] and
they're just like jesus [ __ ] christ
yeah here we go here we go
you know what i mean so
you know the best goal-oriented behavior
we don't like that the best mating
strategy is [ __ ] self-improvement
self-development
be sure just be a cool
be an interesting person right and be
interested in other people wear cool
clothes [ __ ] get into some [ __ ]
develop yourself go into [ __ ] social
[ __ ] circles make friends
you know if you don't have any friends
you're not getting laid
you're just not
yeah because everyone's going to be
suspicious why don't you have any
friends
it's a long-term [ __ ] thing and when
women the main thing women look for is
[ __ ] status
um and status can mean a lot of
different things doesn't necessarily
mean rich
status is social status she's looking
for a guy who everybody already knows
everybody already approves of you
then you started [ __ ] becoming well
the thing about it is that because from
our point of view if we don't know you
if we don't know you there's something
wrong they're like well no what i was
gonna say what i was gonna say is that
if we don't know you but everybody else
knows you and it's like yeah that's a
cool one right yeah then you're gonna
like
a lot of your guard will come down it's
like well everybody knows him and he's
okay like there's no right stories going
around about him about being a creeper
or anything and yeah and he's not doing
anything he's just hanging out he's
hanging out and he's [ __ ] and he's
not trying
yeah right he's just hanging out hanging
out doing this and that being
entertaining and [ __ ] and it's not
ulterior motives that's just who the
dude is yeah people have a [ __ ] real
good sense of what's legitimate that's
the biggest red flag is that you know
that somebody just they don't give a
[ __ ] they're just coming over to talk to
you yeah because they want to [ __ ] you
right yeah and it's really obvious that
they're doing it they're not interested
in you as a person they're not
you know they just like saw you across
they're like that one's hot i'm gonna go
like [ __ ] pick on that it's like
these dudes that come over
with obvious ulterior motives to pick
some chick up in one of these meat
markets
he would think well man he must be the
aggressor
he must be the [ __ ]
no
the only woman that accepts that [ __ ]
she is equally as aggressive as that
dude she's looking for something
the only girls that fall for that [ __ ]
they're thinking like how much money
this guy has i gotta get out of the
apartment i'm in i'm gonna move into his
apartment that kind of [ __ ]
so
now that's not in the goth scene for the
most part it's just not there but if you
go to those meat market scenes those
dudes running around like a meat seeking
missile those girls are in there too
looking for some kind of an exchange
that's why i never went to them [ __ ]
places
every one of those girls yeah every one
of them girls is
in a way a loser
there's something about i mean everybody
is like just looking for something like
something out for themselves yeah
and it's like i hate that right that's
why i'm always glad that like i
busted off early and like went into the
goth scene because there's yeah there's
a lot of drama in the god scene too but
it's just kind of like
at least it's much smaller it's a much
smaller community everyone kind of knows
each other if somebody like [ __ ] up
everybody knows about it yeah so it's
like yeah avoid that person or that
person did this and it's like we don't
want to like associate with them anymore
so that's fine but it's just kind of
like at least you know that you have
like a common interest you're not
getting like some random ass
[ __ ] coming up to you pretending
hey i like beaches too yeah you know
what i mean it's just kind of like
sports and parasailing [ __ ] out
i was like i hate that i hate that
it's like if you're not into the same
[ __ ] as me if you're not like
like i said if you're not interested in
me as like a person
then
you can [ __ ] right off i just i really
don't i'm not about that i'm just not
oracle usually with the girls in those
other scenes
they want somebody to pay their rent or
they got well they want somebody to help
pay for those kids that's usually what
it is all right and they're gonna use
these [ __ ] horny ass suckers as a
vehicle to get that done
and is it due to horny sucker yeah he's
a harness [ __ ] sucker he is
most of them are
that's that's the worst case scenarios
but it's also kind of like the baseline
of the [ __ ] meat market scene
yeah see that's why i never got if she
didn't need anything she wouldn't be in
the meat market
and usually that's what it is kids and
rent
yeah oracle says the ultimate sign of
non-interest reading a book in public
right do not interrupt me when i'm
reading oh my god
how many times like i could you know a
long time ago like before i got a car
um and i used to take public
transportation so i stick the bus
everywhere
and i would always either have
headphones on or i'd be reading a book i
cannot count the number of times
somebody came and sat next to me
even though i had like my backpack there
because i don't want anybody sitting
there unless the bus was full i mean
i'll move it then because i'm not a jerk
but people come to this what are you
reading
i was reading a book and enjoying it
very much before you got up in my
[ __ ] face and like started talking to
like get the [ __ ] away from me i'm
reading a book obviously i don't want to
talk to you
i don't understand like why people feel
the need to like invade a stranger's
i don't know it's just that's so weird
to me
it would never literally never occur to
me
to go up to a complete stranger
and like interrupt what they were doing
and they're clearly like enjoying
themselves like reading a book or
whatever hey what are you doing please
pay attention to me i don't really get
that i don't get that but a lot of
people are like that i guess
i don't get it though i've never been
like that i would never
i would never have the audacity so it's
like every time somebody did that
i would always just be like what the
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] raised you
get the [ __ ] away from me you know what
i mean like i would say that now when i
was younger i was like too shy to say
that i would just be like
a book what does it look like i would
just like go away please go away
nowadays i'd probably just go pap let's
just like hit him with the book
[ __ ] off find another seat
but you know i'm old now i don't give a
[ __ ] anymore
you said the the meat market scene is
wild in the midwest it's always the same
[ __ ] yeah
he calls it the human zoo i go to watch
all the horny humans mating rituals yeah
we see some of it at mannequins uh
adriana says i thought guys in the
galaxy were quite intense like roz
williams from chris no no
uh well it's it's a wide spectrum just
like everything friend of mine [ __ ]
hung out with roz [ __ ]
a little javier who's a dj up in boston
hung out with roz
raj was cool uh but roz had big big drug
problems
raz [ __ ] could do kind of what he
wanted uh in the goth scene and that was
another era
i'm not sure
you couldn't act like that today in the
goth scene and get away with it he was
it was just another time
adriana says john cusack and jeff
goldblum are hot yeah they are
uh and them in my yard with a boombox i
would do them
yeah i probably would do i probably
would too not gonna lie
because they have like
they have that it factor
you know
like i said that's that's maybe what a
lot of guys don't understand about women
is that
both of those dudes are like totally hot
maybe not like physically hot like not
what you would think of as hot but they
have like they're very like charismatic
so i'm like
i don't know
it's in there somewhere
it's probably underneath all the other
wigs
because i just stopped i stopped hanging
them up i used to hang them all up but
you kept like flinging them everywhere
so i just gave up
he messed up my closet
i even i bought like all these things on
amazon where you could like hang your
wigs it's like a hanger and it's got
like a like a wig thing on it like it's
plastic and you can hang them on there
so it keeps them all right
wow you haven't put on wigs in a long
time
you got your joe dirt wig on
yeah the thing about i don't know i i
feel like there's not really
in the scene nowadays because you have
such an age spectrum
i mean we have friends that are
everywhere from 19 to
55. yeah a lot of them are old fat guys
now so it's kind of like all across the
board you so you can't really like
categorize
yeah um
i got my rowdy roddy piper [ __ ] wig
on that's right [ __ ]
you're like you got me kick ass michael
kanewick now michael canwig's in there
i'll come up with that [ __ ] oh that's
right
it's funny because the michael caine wig
is actually technically it's a willy
wonka yeah it is but when we were
looking for a wig when he wanted to play
michael caine from the hand which is
what he dressed up as that was the
closest i could get that was like i was
like well that's pretty close because he
had some like [ __ ] willy wonka
looking at us there look at that [ __ ]
movie
can i ask you something i i gotta i
gotta get i'll get the i'm not gonna
talk like michael kane yeah you're
getting you're [ __ ] like i'm [ __ ]
up i gotta have the wig on
i mean when you're like is it [ __ ]
you is he [ __ ] you oh you did it
anyway yeah
[ __ ] michael kane when you're like
that you gotta do like redneck [ __ ] that
was oliver stone flick if you guys never
seen the hand go [ __ ] check that [ __ ]
out but it was a good [ __ ] horrible
that movie scared the crap out of me
very good well-written oliver stone
horror movie
that's a little bit deeper with a deeper
[ __ ] meaning to it and it references
conan because he was working on conan
too
it's all about toxic mess it's all about
toxic masculinity it is actually yeah
the can the hand is about toxic
masculinity oh for a big time big time
real toxic masculinity not
fake toxic masculinity like he is the
people complaining about is real and it
references conan which
was spoke was healthy masculinity a lot
of people [ __ ] well going on with no
no no you got to go back and [ __ ]
watch the original conan one conan conan
had a good good um had a good
relationship with people and women and
uh under was into strong women and you
know he was he was conan was a good dude
in in um
in conan one
he was very niche and about personal
growth
and um
he understood the sacred feminine
the eye of the serpent
i said well how could the serpent be
feminine
there's talking about asherah and ashura
poles
um asherah was the serpent from the
garden of eden
um
in the original story ashrae was god's
wife it's like hera hera and zeus but
they edited that story to turn
to get rid of to omit
[ __ ] asherah
to make it more uh monotheistic
and she was transformed into a snake
because her thing was snakes it's a
weird concept you have an egg
which goes in the ground and it comes
out as a serpent and then it makes an
egg in the ground it comes back in the
serpent the egg is female and a serpent
is male it's kind of like this
never-ending cycle how does a how does a
a snake reproduce you look at them
they're not they don't have any gender
that's what the ancients thought because
you couldn't see any
sexual organs on a [ __ ] snake so they
just thought that an egg
it was just it was one of the ancient
mysteries you know
in that closet door open well okay it
was oh yeah i should go in there and
[ __ ] it up yeah well because she goes in
there and yeah
she almost strangled herself one of my
bras one day
so i keep it closed now she gets mad
about it but you're right she's like hey
open the door open the door
scarface great oliver stone movie yeah i
like scarface it's good i gotta see that
one again
i wanna own i wanna own scarface
somebody send me scarface on blu-ray if
you if you all want to send me scarface
on blu-ray i'll do a review you're
shameless i'm shameless like a
[ __ ] you are john smith says fun
michael k in fact he only legally
changed his name before maurice mikelway
to michael cain in 2016.
that maniac mitch is a good thing to
[ __ ] ariana
he says roz was a bit extreme but he was
just a character he played it was kind
of a character he played on stage yeah
he wanted to be a goth bowie and he did
sound like a goth bowie especially early
on [ __ ] well and he covered a couple
bone songs like he covered time which is
actually roz was good
he killed himself on [ __ ]
april fool's day
to our surprise that was what
98
97 something like that on april fool's
day it was like that dude killed himself
man
heroin
i think heroin i think he thought heroin
was destroying him and holding him back
forever and he felt like a fool and
died
killed himself
yeah it's just i don't know it was my
take on it
so it's just kind of hard to say i don't
know it's just like every other
i guess from the outside it looks like
monolithic i suppose like the god scene
but just like everything else it's a lot
more
it's just people like everything like
everything else
so we have like [ __ ] got ways
yeah there's really nothing that you see
that sort of like applies across
everyone no everybody like i said
because
i mean the cool thing about the god
scene that i always thought was was one
of the things that i mentioned earlier
that is that it spans like multiple
generations at this point because a lot
of people we know that are our age
have kids that are grown yeah um that
are also into the scene and they'll
bring them out to the clubs and [ __ ]
like boyfriends or girlfriends with
their boyfriends or girlfriends so it's
like a really weird i don't know i guess
like from a normal standpoint it's kind
of weird but for us it's not like really
that was what church used to be like
yeah it's what it's like like church
it's a lot more fun than more important
well i think i think church used to be
fun when that was all there was was
church ever fun uh yeah i think it was
fun when when you spent all day toiling
in the [ __ ] in the uh in the fields
yeah but then like your standards were
way lower your hand
you go in there and you'd hear them
talking and they put on a show and sing
songs and you saw a [ __ ] stained
glass and it was pretty inside there and
it was probably the only time you were
in a pretty building you know [ __ ]
and then yeah
we saw god you know okay get back to the
field you know that's that's just like
that that the the
the temple scene in ancient rome seems
to have been the club scene i mean
that's what it was they were in there
dancing singing listening to music and
taking drugs
and watching animatronic robots do weird
things
that was
and it made a lot of money
so i would think that the roman temple
scene was was the club scene
that'd be the well it's not like they
had anything better to do anything else
to do it was the biggest it was the
biggest industry in the city so it's a
thing one of the biggest industries so
it would have been like theater and
clubs
at the same time and then the theme was
the themes of those temples was weird
you know i mean they had sexual themes
or
drinking milk out of pregnant women
themes and
you know well they knew what brought in
the peeps yeah they're like hey we're
trying to make money off this endeavor
so we know what's else so you know yeah
and they were all competing
with each other
an interesting story see you later john
smith he says the hour grows late for me
so i'm gonna have to retire for the
evening have a good and y'all
good night good night holy perish of
doom says horror and metal icons
typically observe
that fans and conventions always are the
nicest people even though they don't
appear to be so honestly i found i found
that to be true my life through my life
as well um i know this doesn't apply
across the board because i've known some
creeps in my time also
but
generally people that are into
horror or into goth or into like metal
or into like anything like that
they tend to be
nicer people
generally i mean from in my experience
and i know that that's anecdotal but
they do tend to be like nicer people
than
regular ass looking people
at least in my experience
you know what i mean and maybe that's
maybe other people have found that as
well i'm not really sure and we've kind
of talked about maybe why that is is
because i kind of feel like people that
are into horror or people into goth or
metal or whatever they kind of like wear
their dark side on the outside
so you know what you're getting you know
what i mean whereas like somebody that
is trying really hard to be normal or
trying to fit in
you don't know what kind of [ __ ]
nefarious [ __ ] is going on like
underneath the surface that they're
trying to cover up
so i'm always like naturally distrustful
of people like that because i'm like
what are you trying to sell me like what
i don't know like what's going on behind
that facade you know what i'm saying
whereas i feel like people that are gods
or something like that we're just like
not we don't have a facade because this
is just kind of like
this is what we're like and this is what
we look like on the outside well yeah
yeah there are fakes yeah there are and
and then there's
sometimes you know
young people come in the scene and they
got a certain zeal to them they they're
trying to make a name for themselves and
they're trying to be respected in a
scene that they didn't that they that
they've just kind of
just joined have just become a part of
maybe only a couple years
and uh they uh they get [ __ ] you know
hoity toity i guess you could say or
you get a little stuck up
that never lasts though they're just
trying to make it kind of an impression
on other people and then they get a
little bit older they're like yeah this
isn't this very serious like no this
isn't serious
this is just clubs people we're saying
people are getting high and they all
know each other and [ __ ] drinking and
[ __ ]
we wanted to get drunk and like dancing
good too that's not really and then like
they're
so you have that too it doesn't matter
that's normally very young women
they're like that you know
just new to the scene
sometimes you'll see that and they're
also like the real hot ones really young
real hot their first couple years
they're
trying to make a name for themselves i
guess you could say
you know
the thing about it is that i mean hot
people do well everywhere but i do kind
of feel like hot women in particular
especially if they're like really young
if they're used to being like really
young and really hot then they're just
kind of like used to getting their way
so i kind of feel like they're like well
whatever i do i'm gonna be successful
because i'm young and hot and that's
always like successful and to an extent
that works
but
after a little while
if you don't really have any like
substance to back that up or
you know it it's gonna like blow up in
your face well they'll try to be better
than everybody else but they can't exist
on their own yeah there's the scenes
they're small too scene's too small yeah
but they got some real hotties i mean
you know what i mean uh
they got real hotties some of them stick
with it some of them don't um
but eventually you know
after a couple years in the scene they
they just they start chilling out and
kind of becoming every like everybody
else you know well we kind of give them
a lot of leeway when they're young
because i'm like look we were all young
and dumb too and we didn't know what the
[ __ ] we were doing at that age i
remember yeah kind of um you know so
you're gonna like give you'll cut them
some slack
they'll grow out of it yeah most of the
time
most of the time
now not they don't do damage to people
like me and jenny because
we're kind of aloof from that the ones
they [ __ ] up or young guys who are
trying to get them
trying to get some of that well
sometimes they'll sometimes don't lie
about them though you know they just try
to get them kicked out of the club and
best thing to do is just you know
just
stay away from them
[Laughter]
yeah you don't want that yeah and
they're they're gonna they're gutting
for uh a certain kind of goth guy anyway
they're gunning from the same [ __ ]
they're gunning for the same [ __ ] top
ten that all the other girls are [ __ ]
gutted after
again guys that are in bands and [ __ ]
you know
kind of like the dudes [ __ ] dudes
from misfit toys and [ __ ] you know
they're going for guys like that
yeah
i mean those are yeah those those are
those are good-looking dudes yeah young
good-looking guys in their [ __ ] 20s
the early 30s [ __ ] mid-30s you know
they're [ __ ] going for that those
guys are all they're all starting to get
[ __ ] regular girlfriends though now
so they're not they're not on the market
like they used to be no
yeah
it's just hilarious to me how
i guess i don't know i guess people that
aren't in in in it like don't really
like think about it but it's like yeah
we have like a whole other
we have our whole other thing going on
and like i said yeah there's a lot of
drama and i kind of feel like there's
you know even within the scene like
people make jokes about oh the dra oh
goth drama blah blah blah but i don't
think it's any different than the drama
that goes on in like regular kind of
[ __ ] we don't have any more drama than
anybody else does and in fact we might
have less drama
i kind of feel like in a lot of ways we
have less drama than like regular stuff
but
you know because we're gods we have to
like play it up like it's like the worst
drama ever i don't think it's like this
guy
i'm thinking of uh who damien damien
yeah damian well he has a girlfriend
he's got a girlfriend i'm going to show
you who it is he's had a girlfriend for
a really long time
jenna shay yeah janice
there's damian they come to mannequins
they sell their art yeah
pretty much every friday night there
yeah damian's a real good looking tall
he's a painter mixed guy
and [ __ ] photographer yeah
and he sells his art at mannequins like
pretty much every friday night him and
jenna shearer there yeah they have like
a booth set up try to get a picture of
him and jenna's [ __ ] together
i'm sure there's got to be because we've
known him [ __ ] ever pictures
differently yeah
she's sucking she's [ __ ] uh hot too
let me see
here they are
yeah yeah
yeah so that's kind of what you're
dealing with of when it comes to like
top echelon from the scene and he's real
cool [ __ ] they're they're they've
been there they're both actually really
cool yeah we've been friends with them
forever
we've done a lot of events together you
know [ __ ]
through um mannequins and stuff
but [ __ ] we've known him for a [ __ ]
while over 10 years now [ __ ] it's a
long time yeah well we knew him when he
was back with him with brie with brie
brie yeah i mean brie is cool too brie
was cool also
but yeah she she went off and did around
because they broke up a lot a while back
granthar's ass are goth women more
introverted than normies as a general
rule no
i don't know if i would say that like
some of them are i am but um that
doesn't apply across the board like i
said it's very very
it's very diverse
i mean
out of all the women that i know that
i'm like really close to i'm probably
the most introverted i would think yeah
bree's not in the scene anymore
yeah i haven't seen her in a long time
yeah because the only bree i'm getting
is uh the other bree
bree asbrick
oh yeah okay that's the other brie okay
here's a good example of uh
that's kind of a
goth hottie oh yeah that's what's her
name she's been around a long time yeah
i got a story of me and her ex remember
i sent the x off and he went off to
[ __ ] oil rigs and [ __ ] got rich
yeah that's right yeah
she's been around for a while she's been
around for a long time
she's cool also yeah i mean
99 of the people that we know like in
the scene are cool
yeah every now and then you get like a
weirdo but
not usually because like i said the
scene is
and it's kind of like a carrier between
like orlando people and tampa people
because we kind of like
you know they're they're close enough
together that we kind of like get
overlap
but everybody kind of knows everybody or
knows somebody that knows everybody
so if you're [ __ ] up it's gonna
get to everybody like pretty pretty
quickly you know what i mean like if you
do some like creepy or rapey ass [ __ ]
like
everybody's gonna know about that like
pretty much immediately and everybody's
gonna be like okay [ __ ] you dude and
then no one's gonna talk to you yeah and
it has happened
uh where that where that's happened
where everybody found out about one
thing and everybody's like okay we're
not talking to that dude i'll show them
what the new ones are looking like the
young ones are looking like this they're
taking it back
to kind of like the death rock look
which i'm a big fan of yeah this is kind
of looking glad there's another revival
because this is the look that we grew up
with and they're bringing that well and
i kind of feel like in the early 2000s
like or the well more like the mid-2000s
i feel like there was a death rock
revival because that was when i went to
new york and i went to the drop dead
festival and there was a lot of people
there was a lot of like more
newer like death rock bands coming back
or like with more of that sound like
bloody dead and sexy instead of a
strange and
uh [ __ ] like that
and so i was like woo i'm all about it
and then it kind of like came and went
but it seems like lately
it's kind of coming back again which i'm
yeah i'm all for that that's 80s as [ __ ]
i'm all for that yeah because that death
rock [ __ ] with the [ __ ] faux hawks
and stuff see i love that i love that
and that like [ __ ] suzy eyes yeah i
love that [ __ ] yeah she's she's
excellent she's not local so bring that
[ __ ] back she's not local to us well
that's timeless she's yeah but we have
these these are starting to show up now
yeah well yeah that's how that's how we
ended up meeting nick and his you know
was his girlfriend is because they were
like clearly very young they were like
18 19 20. but they looked really old
yeah they looked like all death rock and
i was like oh these kids know what it's
about yeah let's go talk to them
that's this is the same girl as the
other ones but that is like the old
classic look
yeah see we love we love that but
they've amped it up
because
the clothes are easier to get now and
also good hair color is easier to get
now yeah but that's a big thing which
just [ __ ] sucks because now we don't
have hair or at least i don't
well yeah it is a lot i will say that it
is a lot easier it's easier to keep that
look up like than it was back in the old
days because now you can buy the clothes
online you don't have to like go to
thrift shops or make your own [ __ ] or
whatever
the hair dye is much better
the makeup quality is much better like
you can get better quality for like
lower price
you know it's just easier to get [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] man you can buy black nail
polish
at the [ __ ] dollar store nowadays
back in the old days
back in my day yeah
we used to have to wait until halloween
which was the only time they ever had
black nail polish and then you'd like
buy the cheap ass [ __ ] and you'd have to
like buy a whole bunch of it yeah like
to stock up for the rest of the year or
you'd have to do your nails with like
these sharpies yeah because they didn't
sell it they didn't sell it the rest of
the year it was
it because it was considered a weird
color it was only like normal at
halloween time that was the only time
you could buy it but
so mundanes crash and see oracle
oh come goth women don't smile in photos
is that a secret rule because it causes
wrinkles [ __ ] that's why
because it makes you look more accept
more accessible see
yeah we don't we don't want to be
accessible aloof yeah yeah we don't want
every [ __ ] like [ __ ] be like oh
look at you with your cute and yeah [ __ ]
that
we're not happy piss off no i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding
i like to smile in my pictures because i
think if i try to look aloof in my
pictures i just kind of look
i don't know not good
i think i look better when i smile in
pictures but
there's that but i i just
i have done like some photos where i try
to look like moody and like [ __ ]
introspective and stuff and it's like i
always like look really bad
so i kind of like stopped
sadly i don't i don't have i don't have
that that
that goth like
far away like aloof look i just don't
have it like my face doesn't work like
that
i just look better when i smile
unfortunately so i always have to like
smile in my pictures but like i said i
don't i don't know i don't like to smile
because it kind of like i don't know i
feel like it causes wrinkles
i'm real i'm
no grandpa was a boring normie or is
still a boring for me
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i don't know i don't know what that's
like
jenny how has your style changed from
when you began in the scene and now
um
well i have a
slight amount more money now
and a little bit more
i don't know i i kind of feel like when
i first started out
my whole thing was i had like zero money
like because i grew up like pretty poor
so everything that i bought had to be i
either had to save up for like a whole
year like all my birthday money or
whatever or i had to like go to a thrift
shop and get it and kind of like alter
it myself
so i kind of feel like when i was
growing up a lot of my stuff was just
kind of like comprised of whatever
i could get my hands on
so i had like old lady like black lace
dresses that i bought for like a dollar
at the salvation army and kind of like
fixed up and then like i like i'd cut up
an old
t-shirt and like put it over it and you
know and i'd get like combat boots from
the army navy store because they were
cheap and [ __ ] like that so
so one thing is like i do have like more
of a better idea of what looks good and
what fits right and i can actually like
choose what i want rather than just like
going to a thrift store and just going
like oh well i'll make this work
something yeah those days are over yeah
because that was well that was what i
could afford when i was younger
and also the availability and yeah that
too you couldn't just it and maybe like
people that are younger it's like really
hard to
um didn't find anything you couldn't
find anything you either had to like go
to thrift stores and buy [ __ ] and alter
it or you had to sew your own [ __ ] yeah
or
or you had to order stuff yeah from
overseas and it was really expensive
like from black rose like the first time
that i ordered like a real like steel
bone corset yeah
from like someone that made them it was
like 350 dollars yeah
um you know and it was like just
specifically made for me and it was like
a big deal like i saved up for like a
year and a half to buy it and it's like
you don't really have to do that anymore
and and she was younger back then so the
budget is a lot smaller well that's what
i was saying like you kind of just had
to
i basically had to shop at three shop at
thrift stores or you had modified stores
or you had to go to like walmart and
it's like well this is black and this is
black and i can kind of cut this up and
like maybe i can see you had to like
kind of buy stuff at regular stores but
like alter it to like fit your style
more so you had to do that too nowadays
you can kind of get exactly what you
want yeah it was hard being got that it
was kind of harder it was harder well
you had to put more work into it and
you had to get a damn outfit together
you might only really only have two
outfits maybe three
and then you just changed the
accessories you couldn't find anything
yeah they make it
it's first wife was making a lot of her
clothes a lot of people did yeah i'll
show you a lot of people [ __ ] that she
made that was well like i said i used to
i used to get [ __ ] at thrift stores like
i'd buy like old lady dresses that were
like black lace or whatever and then
like kind of try to alter them or cut
them up so they look more punky or
whatever like you'd be doing [ __ ] like
that
you just kind of had to work with what
you had you couldn't really unless you
could afford
to order [ __ ] from black rose yeah but
that was in england and that was like
really really expensive and it was like
really expensive to like
you know for the shipping overseas and
everything like that that's what that's
what a good mid-90s goth checklist that
was my first wife did you see what she's
wearing that's stuff that was just kind
of made yeah
okay well like i said i kind of feel
like you you also went to like walmart
and target and places like that and like
picked up like cheap black leggings or
like cheap black sweaters like [ __ ] like
that and like altered it to more like
fit the style yeah
so you layer things together so they
looked more alternative
right because they didn't really i mean
they made things that were goth
but a lot of the stuff that was
specifically made like to look goth was
really expensive yeah like i like i said
i saved up to buy a course at one year i
saved up
there used to be um those are 90s goths
right there yeah yeah there used to be
was the other one was black rose which i
don't know if it's still there but it
used to be in camden market because i
used to order from there and then i
actually went there in the 2000s
and they still had the booth but um
ouch
oh man my hip got me
but um what was i saying
i got distracted by talking about where
you buy that's me
90s
i think that was uh
97
but you see that's like a that's
actually a vintage
coat from the 1880s i put new buttons on
it and everything i had a little ass
that was another thing that we had a lot
of fine stuff i have had to like look
for yeah i had big tall
like 40 hole doc martens on and uh pvc
black shiny pvc pants and [ __ ] gloves
and [ __ ]
you have to admit you had to make stuff
one of the other oh one of the other
places of like i said black rose was
kind of the famous one but there was
another one
um and i think she's still around or she
was around a couple years ago because i
remember seeing her in gothic beauty
gabriel was her name yeah i know her
gabriel yeah i know her yeah yeah and um
yeah i know yeah um but she had a
company too and she would like custom
make a lot of clothes and i saved up one
year and bought this gorgeous like green
velvet dress and had these bell sleeves
with lace and it's like i [ __ ] love
that dress and it was so so expensive
but i like saved up and saved because it
was real velvet you know what i mean so
you really had to like save up for like
a really long time to like buy a really
special outfit if you were going to like
some thing but the rest of the time
there wasn't there i mean where i grew
up we didn't have hot topic until
the early to mid 2000s
and even then that was like kind of
sketchy you could find a kind of find
some good [ __ ] in there like good tights
and fishnet shirts and [ __ ] and
sometimes you can find some cool dresses
in there but you know back then
but that's jenny about a year ago
getting ready i [ __ ] had to take that
picture she's got her horns on her
[ __ ]
boots and the booty and [ __ ] and
you can see me in the mirror back there
if i can take a picture
that was that was that was at our old
house that's the old house that was a
good pit
fixing my wig fixing the wood
[Laughter]
fixing my wig
yeah it was it was a lot harder back
then yeah i mean now
[ __ ] man i can just go on amazon and
it's like oh hey look at that cool goth
dress and it's just like 20 bucks yeah
they didn't have that [ __ ] back when we
were here no nobody sold that no
it was either
thrift shop or
three hundred dollars yeah you know what
i mean that was like no in between
here's another night this is this is at
um
what was that that southern night
southern knights
that used to be that
well it's still there i think yeah it's
a gay bar yeah but they used to do like
a big fetish party like once a month
that was called escape
and yeah we used to
go to that every month that was super
fun
that was that time when that girl was
here visiting yeah she's from england
that's right it's a british girl
she was here visiting us yeah
that was a fun night i don't remember
what the theme they used to do themes
remember that
yeah i don't really remember
i remember the dark disney one because i
was scary poppins one time yeah
i still have the
parasol and the little hat that i wore
for like scary poppins
oh here's another good one
that was probably that was the same
night wasn't it i think it was the same
night yeah that because that's the same
outfit i was wearing the same outfit our
faces aren't coming in
yeah well
come on face
there we go
that was more of an industrial look
right there that night dj maniac says
i'm wearing my vinyl pants tonight last
night of the season i can pull this off
i'm heading out night everyone good
night dj maniac have a good time
be safe
zach says for halloween one year you
guys should dress up as normies
everybody says that
i don't think i could pull it off though
i don't i don't i'm not entirely sure i
know how to look normal it wouldn't look
impressive
yeah everybody would just be like so
what well
here's one thing i always remember one
night and i think this was a year
probably like two years ago i think it
was two years ago
at memento mori they had their halloween
party
and
i look at the door because we were at
the front bar because we always get
there early now we were at the front
part like watching everybody come in
and somebody came in
that looked like
this is hard to explain
they looked normal but they kind of
looked like an old like um
yeah you know who i'm talking about like
like maybe like a 70s or 80s like house
brow type situation
and i'm looking like what the [ __ ] is
that about i'm like oh my god that's
[ __ ] shauna yeah
holy [ __ ] okay so like our friend shawna
who has been on the show before like a
long time ago yeah he's like this total
punk rock chick she's uh she's from
she's from uh
what what is it called like
massachusetts yeah she's from she's from
uh jamaica plain i think no no no no uh
[ __ ] where is it
god damn it she calls him she calls
herself a mass holder oh no no yeah yeah
yeah she's she's from [ __ ] oh yeah go
ahead go ahead brockton brockton
brockton yeah she's from brockton
and so she is like
oh my god she's [ __ ] hilarious and
her and her her and her husband they're
they're well they're married now um you
know he's like this
old-school like punk skater dude
and she has like she's [ __ ] she's
awesome she's hilarious she has like
these big long [ __ ] dreads she's like
totally and she's into punk rock and on
goth and all this other kind of [ __ ]
yeah and there because i remember her
she had the demon baby doll yeah exactly
oh my god she's awesome i love her yeah
and so like she shows up at the club
jess is kind of an old lady
she looked like something damn that this
[ __ ] wig and she had like a a
cardigan and like and she was carrying
the purse like this and she's
committed yeah to the [ __ ] and like
sneakers she even like walked like the
thing and she was like carrying the
purse like this and i was just like oh
my god
as soon as i realized who it was i
[ __ ] died laughing yeah and she like
committed to that role like the whole
entire night she even talked like that
like she did oh my god it was so [ __ ]
adriana says the foha and the egyptian
eyes is cool and sexy yeah that's
actually taken from susie from susie in
the band she's she was doing that stuff
kind of like not so much late susie but
mid middle of the career yeah yeah she
kind of did that
i kind of feel like she was sort of like
the template right of the for the guy i
mean people were kind of doing that
before then but she was kind of like
codified
this sort of like goth look yeah if you
want to know what goth girls are listen
to susie and the veggies start through
their catalogue that's kind of the
evolution there that's that same and
then madonna saw that and ripped it off
madonna was a susie ripoff pretty funny
for a while
i mean because especially like yeah like
early madonna like when she still looked
kind of cool yeah she's like look i got
fishnet shirts on i'm kind of edgy and
[ __ ] like that i'm like well
not really but okay um she tried well
she was like edgy in like a mainstream
sort of way i guess yeah
but i still did kind of like lucky star
and holiday and all that kind of stuff
it's not right
i like some early madonna i'm not no
shame
yeah so tammy remembered so
i mean if you know her in real life um
it would be much funnier to you like see
her to see her dress like that it just
seemed like she was going
like her husband was going to the golf
course and she was going to have like
brunch with the ladies like while they
were oh my god it was [ __ ] hilarious
i just [ __ ] died laughing that's
susie right there what year is that
maybe
86
84. yeah i kind of i was going to say 84
though
yeah that's the look that actually
kind of inspired it
when did you put your when did you put
your michael kane wig on a few minutes
ago no i didn't notice yeah
i thought you saw
your [ __ ]
little curly ass wig that's so funny
i mean she's like a fashion icon yeah
you gotta say and the new chicks that
are showing up are kind of playing off
of that
in a certain way
although susie got even more goth
looking later uh just gotta find the
right picture
i mean she kind of had a lot of
she went a little bit later on she went
a little bit more like i i don't want to
say glam but she kind of did like she
went like in a more like 20s
kind of direction she did that as well
because they did the creatures as well
what year was that it's more i think
around 85 maybe that seems like an
earlier picture
the stripes tells me it's 1982. yeah i
could be wrong about that
michael asked tom how are you able to
retire so young
i watch the show on fridays love it well
thank you thank you for driving uh the
va considers me a disabled veteran
so i have 85 of my pay active duty pay
that's how
bundy data said i had black leather
pants once
i have one pair well they're not leather
but they're kind of leather-ish
um
pleather
i don't know they're hot though it's
florida
i don't really have much like cause to
wear them because
you wear them and you're just like susie
right there in a bag of sweat yeah
that's susie
in there
yeah
it like didn't look like it didn't look
like her for a second that's but yeah
that's her it's probably about 80 what
i have no idea why you asking yeah
i think that's about 87. he keeps asking
me like i'm google i could just make up
anything i don't know yeah i think that
might have been around he said i don't
know
yeah susie still looks great too
she's still she does and she's
uh she's ancient she still looks good
yeah how old is she uh she's got to be
60 60.
at least
well a little bit younger than
than uh john lyden
60 something let me see she's got to be
in her 60s it's got to be i mean gotta
be
because i thought she was like
significantly older because i started
listening to her in like the [ __ ] mid
80s
and i thought she was older than me then
yeah she had to be like somewhat older
there's her in her probably late 50s
i don't know if i don't know if the
camera can see it
okay
granthar says kids today don't know the
struggle
they don't
i mean you know
but i don't i wouldn't go back then i'm
not like begrudging them like good for
them i'm glad that it's easier because
it was kind of a [ __ ] back then it
sucked
everything was hard
you know it's like i couldn't i'd go to
a store i couldn't find a single thing i
wanted to wear
and you had to kind of like improvise
everything you had to make your own [ __ ]
you had to like learn to sew you got to
do something you couldn't just like buy
[ __ ] off the rack
it was you know michael's taking into
moving would you recommend texas florida
washington mississippi i would
um either florida or texas well it
depends what kind of weather do you want
if you don't want to do if you don't
like hot weather then don't move to
florida because i hate it i'm human
and it's pretty much like that most of
the year yeah
i was born here and i don't like it
so
if that tells you it all depends on what
it is you're trying to do what is it you
want to do
but i would say just off the top of my
head either florida or texas
you've been wanting a drink
sure all right
adriana says love susie's look in her
manta ray era definitely i'm rock yeah i
mean i'm real into
i really like that death rock look it
doesn't look good on everybody but
in general that's kind of like my
favorite look i'm and honestly that's
kind of like my favorite
sub genre of goth i guess i really
really like sort of like the old school
death rock the one that's like glam
inspired i love that kind of stuff and i
love that look i love that big hair i
love that
like that
makeup and [ __ ] like that but other you
know other subgenres of gothic like i
like the look of that too i really like
um
for a while i think in the 2000s one
thing that was kind of big for a minute
was
cabaret so everybody was kind of like
going back to well not everybody but
there was like a small subgenre that was
going back to like the 1920s so it was
kind of like wearing those little pin
curls and like the
and like the exposed garters
and you know just like 1920s looking
stuff like flapper looking kind of stuff
and i thought that looked really cool as
well but done in a more
goth-centric kind of way so people wear
like corsets exposed
garters they would have like this kind
of like you know 20s looking hair 20s
looking makeup and i thought that looked
really cool
but bunny said in florida even the
rain's hot yeah it is it is that's the
thing you always get excited it's like
oh it's raining it's gonna cool it off
it's gonna get hot no it doesn't yeah it
just makes it harder florida
it just makes it more humid florida's
tropical
it's hotter than brazil i lived in
brazil well there might be some place in
brazil in brazil it might be hotter it
might be hotter up closer to the equator
you know in the in rio amazonas but no
[ __ ] this is this is a tropical
environment
[ __ ]
glass molds here
everything cars mold everything okay
right yeah
they're honestly in florida sometimes i
will go an entire week without going
outside right florida would be
uninhabitable
without air conditioning a big time i
would not live here the population was
small here
in in back in the day because people
were like because
there was no air conditioning
with air conditioning it allowed people
to move here i mean you had people
living here without air conditioning but
the population was small they were tough
be like living in vietnam
or they were more they were masochists
[Laughter]
it's just i don't i'm not a person that
likes being damp all the time
and if you live in florida unless you
pretty much stay inside in the air
conditioning you were just like gonna be
damp all the time and even nowadays like
you know and we have like kick-ass air
conditioning this house which is two
stories has separate air conditioning
for the
lower floor and the upper floor
and this is a newer house so it's like
pretty efficient um you know the
electric bill isn't horribly expensive
um and it runs like pretty efficiently
it keeps it pretty cool in here actually
in this office it's actually kind of
cold sometimes even in the summer i have
to put like a jacket on so i'm not
complaining about that not one bit
but i'm just saying that even in
the winter time
like i'll go in there and i'll take a
shower and then you get out of the
shower and then immediately like five
minutes after you've gotten out you're
sweaty again yeah
in england in air conditioning so
there's a
famous uh youtuber named sargon of akkad
who does political commentary he's a
[ __ ] great guy he's [ __ ] funny
intelligent
one of england's greatest
he took his family here to orlando
florida to [ __ ] disney world a few
years back and he made a video he went
he was at the disney hotel one of those
disney world hotels and he's out on the
[ __ ]
uh
uh balcony and his wife's [ __ ] taking
a video and he can't believe it he's
going i cannot [ __ ] believe it he
because i cannot believe how hot and
humid i mean describing it it's not he
said the same he said this is like
satan's ass crack it it says it's like
being wrapped in plastic and then having
somebody wrap you in a hot wet blanket
and that's exactly what it's like that's
exactly what it feels all the time and
then he looks out from the balcony he's
probably on the 30th floor and and he
can see that because disney owns a [ __ ]
ton of land around that area and they
own swamp land you just see the tops of
these damn trees and it looks like
something out of here amazonas like the
amazon river and i grew up in brazil i
know what it looks like it's exactly
what it looks like you don't see the
river
but no man
this is a jungle it's a [ __ ] huge
[ __ ] swamp
yeah i mean it's dagobah it's a yeah
it's a swamp florida is a swamp yeah and
this is where [ __ ] it's a city on it
yeah it's a swamp stone ponce de leon
looking for the [ __ ] fountain of
youth and all these [ __ ]
and seminal warriors killing people and
[ __ ] here this is some [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of down if these cities weren't here
this would be something straight out of
[ __ ] indiana jones yeah well that's
what it used to be before they built a
city on it yeah so unless you're into
humidity and mosquitoes and giant
cockroaches yeah and alligators yeah um
and bears
i mean the bears probably the bears
probably won't hurt you
but
you know i mean
it's hot y'all and
like i said i can say that and a lot of
people like oh it gets hot here too and
no it's not the same it's not the same
texas is hot but it's dry it's a lot
drier than this place this is totally
different this is totally different i
have never experienced like i've been
other places too but like in florida and
like i said i was born here so you'd
think i'd be used to it in the
summertime like oh it's nice and air
conditioned in the house or relatively
nice and air conditioned in the house
you open the front door to go outside
like to get in your car to go to the
store and it's like a wall
of yeah
hot dampness it's like it's like you're
walking into like like you said like a
wet blanket like you open the door and
you're like wrapped in plastic and you
can't sweat it's like that yeah and i'm
just like [ __ ] i gotta walk to the car
now
it's it's so
uh you can't sweat here it's too humid
100 humidity [ __ ] uh uh
yes your sweat glands don't work the way
they are
this hot down there by that mexican
border you know the [ __ ] you're talking
about that's nowhere near heat
i did six months in the sinai desert in
egypt in between
egypt and [ __ ] sinai okay
um about where moses was [ __ ] getting
the damn ten commandments for all i know
all right
it would get to be about 110 115 degrees
out in that sinai desert
and it was cool
it was hot but it was cool compared to
this well the desert there's zero
humidity the desert tends to get cooler
or cold at night and not as cold which
would be nice it'd be very nice florida
that does not happen it uh in the summer
it's still hot cyanide desert could get
up to about
110 degrees probably even hotter maybe
115 in the sun
but because
humidity is zero
you can sweat
and that sweat allows you to cool all
you gotta do is get out of the direct
[ __ ] sunlight because that's what
sweat's supposed to be it's just a
sweater but here you cannot sweat yeah
it doesn't it doesn't work right it's
like being wrapped in plastic
uh because it won't even yeah because it
doesn't um you know it doesn't
disintegrate it doesn't it doesn't you
don't evaporate yeah it doesn't
evaporate that was the word 95 here
feels [ __ ] twice as hot as 110 in in
in egypt it's heavy it's [ __ ] it
feels a little it feels like it's
sitting on your head or sitting on your
face feels like you're being pressure
cooked
yeah it feels like it it feels like a
big fat sweaty sumo wrestler sitting on
your face that's what it feels like it's
too humid
it's just too damn like you can't
breathe yeah
now i've kind of gotten to where i can
tolerate it
i tolerate i think better than jenny
i tolerate it because i have to but like
i said i was born here i was born in
daytona beach you think i but i still i
hate it i just i hate it i tolerate it i
hate it i tolerate i don't enjoy it but
i do tolerate it and a lot of times we
spend a lot of a lot of the summer in
the air conditioning
so we don't have to be out there in it a
lot not during the day time
which makes it easier though because
because
i'm retired and then she works indoors
i'd be working indoors at my age anyway
but i'll work out in here you know we
got air conditioners [ __ ] now look
we've lost our air conditioning before
for about a week at a time
it's [ __ ] unlivable in here without
air conditioning the houses aren't
designed
to exist without air conditioning
there's not enough air flow the windows
are too small they just there's not
enough windows
and even if you open the windows it
wouldn't make any difference the
humidity seeps into all the carpets and
they start to reek no matter how clean
yeah like a day or two later it just
everything starts to reek everything
smells like a wet dog yeah
and and then it starts to smell like
mold yeah it does mold very quickly and
it's it's it's bad
but that's why the old houses here
were victorian plantation style houses
where they had
windows that were also doors made out of
glass that went from the [ __ ] tops of
the [ __ ] ceilings all the way down to
the floor and you can walk out on these
decks
and each [ __ ] room had seven or eight
of them at least five of those [ __ ]
glass doors so what they would do is
they would open every [ __ ] door in
the house and the air would just blow
right through and then eventually they
had electric fans
and then then they started putting
things like screens
but before screens they just opened all
the doors and windows and then they had
a [ __ ] canopy beds where they put a
net over the [ __ ] bed
so they were sleeping outside basically
yeah [ __ ] and [ __ ] come in bats have
come in [ __ ] [ __ ] flying around in
the damn house cockroaches cockroaches
army everywhere that's just
yeah snakes and it was like
it was like that all the way up until
the 60s
because air conditioning really is a
thing of the 60s i can't imagine yeah
those people must have smelled it yeah
in mississippi i can remember being in
the 70s where your air conditioning was
basically window units
and really would only be cool in one or
two rooms because well yeah i mean could
only afford maybe one or two
window units
and they pulled a lot of [ __ ] i said
before i grew up in my grandma's house
her house is built in 1958 with zero air
conditioning yeah they had a window unit
put in later which was in like the
dining room area like right by the
kitchen
in the summer time
everybody had to sleep in the living
room across from the dining room where
the window unit was you couldn't sleep
in the bedrooms in the back of the house
it was too hot it was like it was like
sleeping in an airless yeah wet
hole
yep i remember visiting my grandma when
i was a little kid in mississippi and
mississippi is not as hot as florida
it's hot but it's not as hot as florida
and i'd spend a lot of time i was about
ten six seven eight nine ten you know
someone's five i spent a lot of the day
in her bedroom standing in front of the
damn window unit yeah i did a lot too
when i was a kid
breathing that you had to stand like
yeah you just stand right i used to
stand right in front of the air
conditioner yeah just eating it up yeah
she'd be in the other room
she'd be in the other room
she'd be out in the [ __ ] living room
or the [ __ ] den
watching prices right and all her old
lady [ __ ] programs oh my god like it
was amazing oh my grandmother
too yeah
let's make a deal and all that [ __ ] and
i can hear her and she'd be reading a
national enquirer [ __ ] like okay my
grandmother like it's news
you know like it's new but she loved
prices right yeah then she'd be watching
she'd be reading girl porn like girl
porn but it was romance novels she'd
have whole stacks and they've been
romance novels
you know [ __ ] remember those things yeah
with the little harlequin romance novels
and [ __ ] they still pop they still have
yeah she'd have a bunch of those and um
yeah and i'd just be [ __ ] standing in
front of that damn window unit but she
was hardened to it
my grandma is the same yeah well because
i used to ask her all the time because
like i said they moved down she's from
tennessee
and her and uh her husband who he came
in down to work for nasa
and they moved down in 1958
and they had their house built in
holly hill which is like a suburb of
daytona beach
a little bit inland and i and they
didn't have any air conditioning for
years
and i was like how did you
live how did you do it she was like i
don't know we just got used to it we
used to she's like we used to sit
outside most of them yeah
like they had a big ass porch and they
used to drink like you know iced tea and
[ __ ] like that
um she's like oh and sometimes we would
take the like box fans and we'd put them
in the window and like put a bowl of ice
yeah in front of the fans
and a wet towel and a wet towel yeah
they would do that too they did all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] that we me and jenny
tried that when the air conditioner went
out the old place it didn't help not
really nah should know that i mean it's
probably better than nothing but they
were just kind of they were hardened to
it because they didn't grow up around
air conditioning
um but man my spoiled eyes yeah yeah
we're being asked i thought texas uh we
got like lots and lots of questions that
were boring okay honestly i thought
texas was hotter than florida it may be
but
heat doesn't matter what matters is is
the humidity
okay
if the humidity approaches a hundred
percent you can't sweat
so 90 feels like a [ __ ] sweltering
hell
anything above 90.
because you feel like you
you feel like you can't get any oxygen
like you can't breathe and you can't
everything is like thick it's like
everything is like it feels like like
wet hot things like pushing into your
face in the dead of summer it can get
about 100 and something degrees here
with 100 humidity raining every day
but that doesn't last long maybe about a
month
a couple weeks and then it starts
tapering back off again
oh that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
miserable
if you have to live out in it
just yeah i would just advise like if
you can avoid it like just don't go
outside yeah
i mean if you can avoid it don't go
outside in the summertime yeah but the
shitty thing well the shitty thing about
florida is that
we don't really have seasons yeah we've
mentioned this before like yeah summer
is like miserable it's always warm but
spring is hot yeah
uh fall is hot
even christmas is kind of hot it's just
not as humid it's kind of hot really the
if it's going to get cold
it'll get cold a couple of nights in
like january or february yeah and that's
about it like sometimes it's kind of
like mild
but it'll snow here every decade or so
i mean every now and then people be like
ooh freeze warning it's going down to
like 30 degrees yeah inland like
overnight
but then by the next day it'll be like
ah 60 70 again
yeah you know what i mean so
we never really have a winter we don't
really have and i remember many times
growing up
um christmas we'd have to turn the air
conditioning on at christmas time
because it was it was hot out adriana
says florida's like honduras hot and
rainy yeah yeah in the summer in the
summer the rest of the year it's not
that bad
it's not it's not rainy and it's not
that hot not to me i mean the rest of
the year it's like it's warmer it's
warmer than i would like yeah because i
like cool i like cooler cold weather
yeah um the rest of time it's like warm
it's warmer than i would like but it's
mild a lot of a lot of the year it's 60
70.
you know well not a lot of the year yeah
a couple months out of the year most of
the year it's 70s or 80s yeah that's
what i'm saying and then in the summer
it goes up to 90s hundreds okay 90s
hundreds
thank you zach speaking of hair and
makeup
i think the whole natural look from the
70s is very appealing for women i get a
feeling it's making a comeback at the
moment maybe it is
um it looks good on some people i would
never like across the board say oh this
look looks good on everybody because
nothing look nothing does i don't for me
i don't particularly like
the natural look i feel like if you're
going to wear makeup you might as well
look like you're wearing makeup because
you i feel like i'm not fooling anybody
it's like obviously i have makeup makeup
on um
i don't know it's just my thing
so i kind of like if you're gonna wear
makeup at least make it look
dramatic i i don't know i like dramatic
i like high contrast i don't really like
like natural looking stuff because i
feel like when i do natural looking
stuff i'm like why even bother i'm just
like i don't know it just seems like too
much effort for not enough reward i
guess but some people look good like
that some people look good like that
um let's see i saw another thing oh i'm
gonna wait till tom comes back to ask
that grantham says rando questions
are there any former viewers you miss
uh
former viewers we miss
i'm not really sure because i feel like
all of you guys from the live streams
most of you guys are still here right so
i kind of feel like there's not anybody
that i like really remember as being
like ooh oh there's that person and like
now they're gone
unless i'm like forgetting somebody
but i can't really like think of anybody
that
that i really particularly miss or
anything like that i've had a few people
like kind of like
huff off or whatever but i don't really
remember that much how long we've been
streaming do you
well we have some questions we have
questions another about how long we have
streaming because two hours two hours
and 43 minutes okay we're doing good you
want to eat well in a little while yeah
so we got some questions here okay
um i was gonna say well i said thank you
to zach because he gave us a five dollar
super chat oh thanks yeah and he said
speaking of hair and makeup i think the
whole natural look from the 70s is very
appealing for women and i get a feeling
it's making comeback and i was like well
it depends on what you look like i kind
of feel like i don't i don't
particularly i don't like the natural
look like for myself and i don't usually
like it on other people like i said
if you're gonna wear makeup i kind of
look like do makeup man like do a whole
[ __ ] drama thing yeah but
you know if if it works for you then
that's cool
unless i'm gonna say something to say
he's talking about women
okay
zach
and
for guys who don't know knows that
zach's gay all right
he's looking at these women and all of a
sudden he's getting attracted he's
getting ready to flip on over
to to the dark side that's what's
happening no i'm just kidding
zach here's the thing that natural look
from the 70s that was young women you
look at the damn ages of those women
they're actually younger than they
looked i mean you have to be you pull
that off yeah especially to look good
natural you have to be like pretty young
your skin's real tight right your skin's
like really clear yeah once you get a
little bit older that natural shit's not
gonna yeah it's not gonna work out so
it's not gonna look the same and a lot
of that [ __ ] it was shot with old school
[ __ ] cameras in black and white which
is real harsh
okay without any kind of filters
so you're seeing a woman she looks great
you [ __ ] really do the research and
she starts to see how how old she is
she's 18.
yeah okay
with a good body
you take a [ __ ] 35 year old woman and
shoot her in that same lighting and that
same angles and everything she's not
gonna look good okay then later on some
of that stuff that they would do in the
70s is that they would shoot it in color
but with a soft filter which is real
forgiving
which would make a a woman who was nude
in the poses that they're doing
uh with light makeup you really wouldn't
see that there's makeup but there is
would be real forgiving oh my look how
natural that looks no it's not natural
there's there's a filter on that on that
camera that's diffusing it and there is
makeup there it's just that it's it's
done right well
i kind of feel like
maybe a lot of dudes don't know this
but there's a thing where look there's a
big difference between what a woman
looks like in photographs or movies or
something with zero makeup yeah and what
they look like with
natural makeup natural makeup and
natural makeup is actually quite a lot
of makeup
but
it's a lot of makeup
meant to look like it's not a lot of
makeup but it's still a lot of makeup if
you took pictures of them with zero
makeup on
she would look terrible yeah most of the
time i mean depending on like the
lighting and stuff like that but i do
agree with you that 70s look that they
were trying to get they called that kind
of like the earthy look it was kind of
cool
um
the things that i didn't like about it
is body hair nah
all right trim that [ __ ] okay
you can have hair but just [ __ ] trim
it those [ __ ] chicks were [ __ ]
bushy
okay time to like bush [ __ ] no
um i'm not really a big fan of bushy
well like i said if people want to do
that i'm not i don't really have i don't
care one way or the other but for me it
just seems like i don't like it because
it just seems like yeah i don't know i
don't like it now one of the things that
was kind of good for about the some of
the 70s layouts that they would do is
that the women were voluptuous a lot a
lot of times they they looked within
what would be a healthy weight for women
but there's also [ __ ] they're not
telling you a lot of those women had
implants or silicone silicone injections
so a lot not all of them were as natural
as you're thinking
breast implants go all the way back to
the [ __ ] 40s
okay that that's how far back they go
late 40s early 50s
a japanese invention
actually well back then it wasn't really
you couldn't really talk about it like
everybody was like what no what are you
talking about these are totally my tits
yeah and it came from um japanese
prostitutes
uh who tried to attract
soldiers and
sailors that were american guys who were
stationed there
and japanese surgeons came up with it
and
they weren't implants at first they were
just silicone injections and you still
get that central and south america
just take
don't take [ __ ]
don't take [ __ ] industrial silicone
that shit's not [ __ ] sanitary okay
but they were taking
medical grade silicone and injecting it
just with a regular syringe
nowadays people with their their [ __ ]
their [ __ ]
hair would stand up why would you do
that man they got away with it back then
uh some guys even today say that was
really the way to do it
because what happens is is that it goes
in and it makes a [ __ ] ball of scar
tissue around it and holds all that
silicone in place but you have to do it
right you those women were bound up
to keep it all in place while they
healed and then once it was healed they
could take the bandages off and it would
the silicone would be trapped inside of
a pocket of scar tissue
later on they thought that that's that
that silicone was getting into the
bloodstream which
there's some controversy about that
other people were saying no it didn't
happen
um so they started to hold that into a
pocket
known as an implant a plastic bag
that way that assures that there is no
blood transfer of that silicone getting
into the bloodstream and it won't
migrate over time or move around over
time
that's probably that is definitely the
safer way but the original way was just
to inject it straight in and just let it
heal up
uh they still do today in central and
south america with [ __ ]
industrial silicone which is dangerous
as [ __ ] which can get you could have
infections and rejections because you
don't know what container that [ __ ] was
stored in before you injected it into
yourself they'll try to heat it up try
to kill any bacteria in it
that might work but no don't do it um
the thing is is that
the reason why they eventually got rid
of that is that
it could be that some women were
allergic to that because some women
evidently did have problems with it or
at least they reported it they didn't
feel good
the upside to just injecting it straight
in is that there's no implant it feels
natural it moves natural it looks like
that that's real boob
and you can do it in a butt too
downside it might get you sick over time
that particular woman might reject it
and also if you put it in things like
asses it can migrate it can [ __ ]
slide down over time especially if it
didn't make it into muscle if it's in
the fat it could [ __ ] slide down over
time and kind of end up around your
ankles
or your knees
so they're they're going with implants
but that shit's been around forever
that's what i was trying to tell you
you can see [ __ ] photographs of some
of these girls from the 50s you go god
there's a supernatural proportions might
not be natural
well that's the thing i kind of feel
like that's the problem is that
a lot of things that like dudes are like
oh i love that i love that i don't think
they realize the amount of uh
machinations that are going on behind
the scenes right to make that occur that
is usually not natural yeah a lot not
usually a lot of times they were
injecting things all the [ __ ] dudes like
that's usually like not that doesn't
happen in nature not usually uh if you
look at real old playboy and real old
men's magazines
some things look great but they don't
quite look
right like why isn't gravity taking play
here well the angle they're
photographing around here is hiding the
fact that she's got a bunch of tape on
the other side of the boob pulling it
well yeah well in the photograph too
there's like yeah i used to do that
well they still do that they still do
that they'll tape it on i mean nowadays
they probably do that and then like they
photoshop it like now we have photoshop
so you can fix everything you make
everybody's thighs look thinner look
everybody's got a thigh gap no they
don't it's they did that in photoshop
but you know what i mean but there's a
bunch of old school tricks that they
used and like i said i think they still
do that a lot of times like nowadays
they use like a lot of tape yeah to pull
back
things at certain places because it
makes it easier for the photoshop
artists
being a photoshop artist i know
it's like if you get a good photo to
start with it's like the less work i
have to do the better yeah um you know
what i mean so if you pull all the flesh
back and all the yeah cellulite and [ __ ]
like that then it's that's less
and when it gets less [ __ ] i have to do
this is not confined to women
well they do it to everybody well they
were doing weird [ __ ] with men
people think people are seeing muscle
men back in the [ __ ] 40s and 50s
sometimes 30s and they're going like
well well [ __ ] they didn't have steroids
back then they had steroidal type
things back then that
they were getting their hands on
you can go look at mr universe from the
50s and you're seeing dudes i'm looking
at them and they [ __ ] got some
healthy [ __ ] big strong [ __ ]
with [ __ ] classic physique what they
call it's kind of like arnold
schwarzenegger's
physique not quite that big arnold was
the
pinnacle of [ __ ] classic physique he
was [ __ ] roided out like crazy
for his day um
but you can see guys in the 50s that
looked like that arnold was emulating
those guys
they were getting their hand i'm looking
at them today i'm going there's no way
that's natural
but it doesn't really say what it was
they were doing
it must have been testosterone
there must have been some kind of
[ __ ]
steroidal compounds that they could get
their hands on it's just outside it's
outside
probably
probably steroids for cattle
probably what they were doing
back in the 50s
they must have had something
the only one you know for sure
was natural was eugen sandow
from the eight late eighteen hundreds he
because that was before all that but
they were doing weird [ __ ] like that too
taking a bunch of damn
nuts off of rats and nuts off of [ __ ]
dogs and nuts that came off of [ __ ]
horses and [ __ ]
and put and putting that in center fuses
and trying to get [ __ ] testosterone
out of that
and i
maybe they use that i don't know
they were trying they knew what
testosterone was
okay so we got a bunch of questions and
i'm going to try and give them to you in
a way that will
have like the shortest answer first
because i don't want you like going off
on a big level
no i'm just saying i don't want you
going off in a big long answer and then
like i can't answer the other ones okay
so i kind of feel like maybe this will
be the shortest answer good
uh michael says i asked this silly
question of all dudes i think are
interesting have you ever banged an
asian woman
is asking me yes dude i lived in korea
well i've never banged an asian woman
yeah
i lived in korea for a year man [ __ ]
yeah of course
lots of them
so he's banged lots of asian women so
yeah that's a pain in the ass
are they most of them okay
everyone's a pain in these pain yes
dudes are a pain in the ass
most of them were professionals you know
they were [ __ ] ladies of the evening
they were uh professional entertainers
and [ __ ] uh
you know up on hooker hill and [ __ ]
itaewon they were great girls
really you know i mean korea assembled
an army of young women
to
take as much money out of the pockets of
american army guys they possibly could
they were normal and they succeeded they
succeeded
they were and they went through training
and got [ __ ] uh
language [ __ ] training and cultural
exchange trying to massage their egos
yeah the uh and the us army went in and
made sure everybody they went in there
and inspected them all and tested them
all all the time there was right outside
the it's a nightclub
it is a nightclub environment behind the
nightclub attached to it is apartments
where they live in
and [ __ ] you meet them in the
nightclub and they take you back out
there but it's not as fun as
say like meeting
a real girl you know what i mean she's
because it's like not a prostitute
that's not it's not like that it's more
kind of like uh they're they're
professionals
and it's more like banging the waitress
you know
it's not it's nothing personal
and so well it's just like a transaction
yeah yeah it's just fun everybody knows
what the expectations are yeah yeah most
of them are just it's not like the fun
thing where it's like oh i'm meeting
this random ass person maybe we'll have
sex and maybe we won't yeah it's not
most of it most of them are were um i
guess you could say just kind of like
pleasant
in the way that [ __ ]
your your your
your [ __ ] waitress is pleasant or
you're [ __ ] that waffle house waffle
house
they're cute they were cute
they're like that
but you're not really like into them you
know
um
out of them all there was like only like
a couple of them
that were cool that you would like want
to hang out with
most of them were just didn't have them
like you said it was just like
transactions yeah and they had like
generic personalities because they
that's not who they were they were just
kind of going through a generic yeah it
was like their job that was their job
yeah it was their job yeah
uh granthar's asked i tried to answer
this earlier but i couldn't really think
of anything uh he has some random
questions are there any former viewers
that you miss
yeah sandra where the [ __ ] is sandra
yeah sandra well i don't even consider
her a former viewer because it wasn't
that long ago that she like vanished i
hope she's okay
i hope she's okay german's got her i
mean maybe it's just i know there's a
big time difference sandra used to come
in here and say some funny ass [ __ ] with
her [ __ ]
names and stuff i i used to love her she
didn't get mad at me maybe she got mad
at me maybe i said something she got mad
she either [ __ ] that [ __ ] just
never came back i don't know yeah maybe
you just kind of like piss people off
[ __ ] them no sandra was cool i think
she's all right something must have just
happened to her maybe she lost her job
or something well like i said it's a
different it's a way different time zone
yeah so you know
he also asked what advice would you give
to people who want to be youtube
influencers
are we even youtube influencers
is that such a thing yeah i don't know
um am i an influencer are you an
influencer we're just providing a show i
don't know i don't know i don't think
about it i don't think it's well and
maybe that's the advice that we would
give don't think about it yeah don't
think about it
um just kind of like do [ __ ] you like
yeah like i said
we do this because we just like to hang
out on friday night and like drink and
talk to you guys about nothing yeah um
and we're just having a good time well
it's not about nothing because people uh
i mean not about nothing you know what i
mean yeah i'm being high yeah i'm being
hyperbolic you know what i mean it's
just the normal conversations and
talking about things and you know
keeping keeping you guys at home relaxed
and [ __ ] so you can [ __ ] have a
good drink and sleep and
you know one thing i would okay like one
thing i would say and this is just from
not so much from my experience but from
my experience like watching other
youtube videos about because i watch a
lot of youtube videos researching other
movies and topics that we talk about
don't try
okay don't try to be a personality
just be yourself yeah i think you're
gonna go a lot farther it might take
longer i will say that
but
just be a person don't try to don't have
like
i'm not saying don't have a gimmick
have an angle
but don't have a gimmick yeah you don't
be yourself that's what i'm saying don't
try to be like so because i've seen
i'm not mentioning any names but um i
watch a lot of like horror channels and
there's a lot of them i really like
and there's some of them that i watch
sometimes because they have a review of
some movie that i'm interested in like
watching a review of a movie of um you
know and i watch them and it's very
clear
that they're trying to be
they're trying to like project a persona
like hey what the [ __ ] and they're being
like really fake
and it's like don't do that i i kind of
feel like in the long run that's really
not gonna so that's all i'm saying like
just do what you like
um
and just be yourself
i feel like you'll get it might take
longer but you'll build a bigger
audience doing that than like trying to
project a persona that you think people
will like because that's not gonna work
out no um
what is the hardest thing about living
in florida minus the heat
okay so well the heat is the number one
thing
um
[Music]
i don't know i was born in florida i
don't really like and this is not across
florida as a because florida is like
kind of a diverse place
but a lot of the places are kind of
rednecky
and are kind of like
and i'm not really into that
um so
i don't know i it's for me that's like
the hardest thing a lot of it seems like
a little bit backwards
to me the thing is it's always seemed
like kind of i've been all over the
united states and jenny would find that
same phenomenon happening in every
[ __ ] state because yeah i know
i know she's got it
so it's always you could go up north and
hang out in massachusetts i lived there
for [ __ ] five years
and you'd have that same experience once
you got outside [ __ ] the city yeah i
know that it's like
so it's not
it's not florida specific it's just
specific that's everywhere it's like
that um
besides the heat
florida's easy living compared to say
like california california's in boston
that's [ __ ]
cutting edge it's the
the difficulty is a lot higher
because you need a lot of money to to to
to survive there so you have to make a
bunch of money
it's not so much like that in florida
florida is still the south
there is a place for every budget you
might not like that place but there's a
place for every budget might be full of
roaches
might be out in the middle of fun like
my old apartment was yeah yeah
in winter park right or it might be out
in the middle of nowhere or it might be
out in the middle of nowhere yeah and
also full of roaches yeah some treasure
full of roaches up in the middle of
nowhere
you know well [ __ ] i mean pretty much
everything in florida is full of roaches
this place isn't full of roaches well no
i'm just saying like they can get you
anywhere it's hyperbolic yeah i'm making
a joke it's hyperbolic
but uh no i clean this [ __ ]
place if there's roaches in here even if
you clean it like well they they're
constantly trying to come in there
that's the same thing
this is not um
a civilized place you're no matter where
you are well once you're outside nature
is encroaching nature is trying to come
in
like i gotta go out there tomorrow this
is a [ __ ] nice neighborhood okay
i gotta go out there tomorrow i just
remembered it and put the ladder upside
the house
because the air conditioning vent that
not the air conditioning event the the
dryer vent
has a [ __ ] bird's nest in it
is it woodpeckers i don't know i just
see the [ __ ] because
the last couple days
some [ __ ] woodpecker yeah has
decided he's a peckerwood or a
woodpecker he's gonna peck on this
[ __ ] the side of the house some kind
of bird nest in there it must be a wood
but don't kill them though
okay what i found is if it is wood if it
is woodpeckers yeah
one thing i learned
uh well two things i learned one one
thing they don't like
um
like wind chimes so if you put up wind
chimes they don't like that sound so
they might like [ __ ] off
and another thing oh because remember i
said i heard a wood woodpecker like
pecking at the house in the house yeah
and you were like well they're not
pecking into the wood no they're just
like pecking on the thing they're it's a
mating call yeah so they're not like
trying to get into your house or
anything like that they're just like
kind of trying like hey ladies like here
i am or nothing like that but it is like
really really loud so i have heard that
doing that also they don't like shiny
[ __ ] yeah so they said if you see like
houses in like that have like cd like
old cds like strings of them that's why
because woodpeckers don't like that
because they don't want people like
doing that [ __ ] but don't kill them and
like don't like [ __ ] because i would
feel bad if that happened but um what
was something else i wanted to like uh
answer up here
michael says i drink during the show
like you guys do
okay well yeah we all do
don't we all adriana says ryan hollinger
and you guys are the best horror
channels on youtube oh my god i love
ryan hollinger he is cute as [ __ ] i know
i've never seen that he's an irish guy
and he puts up probably like a video a
week maybe two and i love that he just
picks a movie
at random he doesn't really seem to like
give a [ __ ] about what's popular what if
it's just like whatever he likes or
whatever he wants to deep dive into and
he'll usually do like a half hour or 35
minute
kind of deep dive into the movie why he
likes it and stuff like that but i yeah
i really really like him my favorite
movie reviewer is [ __ ] [ __ ] case
cinema the name of the channel
johnny shitcase he's a british guy yeah
he's [ __ ] funny he's funny really
good writing and he just he'll like do
old sequal movies and [ __ ] well that's
where he found out about neil breen yeah
because he's done a bunch of neil breen
yes he knows shitty movies yeah just
shitty movies [ __ ] that's a showcase
it's [ __ ]
go go check out [ __ ] shitcase cinema
and go look at some neil breen
reviews and [ __ ] i think the last one
he did was neil brady or no the one
before that i think he did it was he's a
[ __ ] british classic that dude he
doesn't put up many videos anymore no
like he only puts up maybe one every
couple months yeah but he's got a
hundreds of them up there but he's super
funny he's a writer also yeah i make him
a [ __ ] honorary southerner
the honorary son he's hilarious
but i love him i love ryan hollinger i
love brian brandon ten old he's canadian
yeah um and he puts up a video
once a week
and he usually does shitty movies too or
shooting movies are like cult movies
yeah um he does a lot of godzilla films
like a lot of japanese films but he does
like a lot of like weird ass
what's the one he did the other day that
like
he did a movie the other day what was it
called
zero
what the [ __ ] was that thing called it
was called zero something
and i had never heard of it but it
looked it was japanese i think but it
looked [ __ ] crazy and tom was like we
need to watch that movie because that
looks [ __ ] epic it did
he finds like the craziest [ __ ] [ __ ]
crazy is [ __ ] g
but he's done some like [ __ ] that we've
covered as well like i think he did
the gate
you know like that canadian movie and
he's done movies we've talked about but
he usually kind of tries to go like real
deep and find like some weird like cult
[ __ ] and he does he's a real big um mst
fan
so he does sort of like a rift style
commentary like where he'll show like
kind of clip to the film and like does
jokes over them but he's like real funny
i like him as well oliver harper is also
really great he's good but i kind of
feel like he's pretty well known at this
point like right because he's made like
documentaries is that the last question
um i don't know i was like way behind
good shark snakes [ __ ] with eco and
yeah okay
small town florida pickup truck drive
around friday saturday night every truck
is higher bigger it has larger tires
than the one before yeah yeah pretty
much yeah and i was like oh so the
penises are just getting smaller smaller
yeah yeah the trucks are getting bigger
and the dicks are getting smaller that's
yeah i mean i don't laugh at the [ __ ]
thing i always kind of wanted like a
i mean i i probably thought i would i
would have got shot like when i was a
teenager but it did occur to me i was
like oh man i always wanted like a
bumper sticker that said the bigger the
truck the smaller the dick yeah but i
figured i'd probably get shots it may
not be true but the [ __ ] are
acting crazy they're compensating for
something i don't understand it man it's
like i'm driving down they're
compensating for something we're not
we're not we're on the edge of the city
we're not out in the middle of the
country [ __ ] uh we'll be heading
towards the club it's [ __ ] dark
[ __ ] country road and it's like a
[ __ ] ufo coming in on the
oncoming line like what the [ __ ] is this
thing and it it passes you and it blinds
the [ __ ] out of you i mean they have
enough [ __ ]
lights on the front of it it's like
[ __ ] five day times all right you can
get a sunburn on this [ __ ] it's coming
at you and when it passes you
it's like [ __ ] three stories above
you
what the [ __ ] was that thing is it good
why do you need that yeah you don't well
it doesn't have anything to do with need
that's what i'm saying well that's
exactly the point
it's it's it's exactly the point that i
make he wants to be taller and higher
and bigger and heavier
and [ __ ] brighter
than than everybody
it seems that's the problem right there
that's what it is my whole thing my [ __ ]
is taller than yours and bigger and
heavier and [ __ ]
more lights you know i want more you
know which i can kind of understand it
good for you but there's diminishing
returns
you know i mean there's diminished and
for people like me
um
how that's gonna read
yeah the more you kind of have more of
that kind of stuff people are gonna
think well that person obviously has
some inadequacy issues in some area
um there's a ladder coming down when
they open the [ __ ] doors they come
down a ladder
it's like straight out of something out
of that mad max fury road this is what
it's like they're like that which how
badass can you be it's like i'm gonna
come down to this truck and kick your
ass wait a second yeah i gotta come down
my ladder yeah
oh okay well
i'll just wait for you to come down then
just
nothing practical about it at all they
go well this is my mud truck
but they don't take it muddy they don't
go into a big mud pit and drive it
around and if you guys don't know what
i'm talking about go on youtube and go
to florida
mud truck
event
and you'll see a bunch of [ __ ] crazy
rednecks and gigantic [ __ ]
trucks with monster trucks
with half naked redneck girls with their
asses [ __ ] hanging out dancing on top
of those things to rap music
you think rap yeah the countries [ __ ]
they listen to rap they [ __ ] love rap
i was at the [ __ ] biker bar and they
were they had those dudes in there and
they [ __ ] requested some songs
new country music that is rap
i was like what the [ __ ] is this
i don't remember the names the bad but
new country sounds like rap
well that makes sense it sounds like
rednecks rapping
with country music and [ __ ] that makes
sense that's that seems like a natural
product that's how it's progressed yeah
because i mean
when i remember [ __ ] like in the 90s and
the 2000s you had like
rock music like
rock music that was old at that time
like classic rock
kind of crossing over with rap so i cut
or hip-hop so i kind of feel like
that was like a natural progression yeah
at that time like new country kind of
sounded more like pop music
like cyrus and [ __ ] yeah like crossbred
with country uh which was also horrible
and horrible but terrible
i lo i look i like old country i like
johnny cash i like that like hank
williams i like that kind of [ __ ] yeah
well what's her name who did [ __ ] um
who dolly parton yeah she was good
[ __ ] uh the girl who did [ __ ] um
uh
[ __ ] uh oh to billy joe what was her
name [ __ ] oh [ __ ] she used to get a
girl from mississippi
oh [ __ ] what are you leaving me for i
don't know you don't remember her name
okay
look it up you got google yeah yeah yeah
i got it i don't know why you like it
i don't know
but it's just kind of like
like that [ __ ] was good but once it's
kind of started to try to like
cross-pollinate with about genres
oh okay bobby gentry oh yeah
i know she was good for millionaires but
so i like a lot of the old [ __ ] but
when it tried to start going like
mainstream or become like kind of
cross-pollinated with more mainstream
genres
at that point it was just like just stop
it it's just like you're just making
those terrible genres worse yeah yeah so
and i'm not i don't know what you're
doing i'm not 100 sure
uh [ __ ] um
that was more like western music
actually than country
dude did [ __ ]
ring a fire and that's johnny johnny
cash yeah i don't think i'm not sure
that was country i think it was more
like just like i mean it's still
probably considered country but
i mean i like that kind of [ __ ] yeah i
like that he was good and i and i even
like
newer [ __ ] that like homages that kind
of [ __ ] because look at look one of my
favorite musicians in the whole world
that cave he [ __ ] loved johnny cash
he covered johnny cash johnny cash
covered one of his songs yeah and like a
lot of the um
you know movie scorers that he did later
on were very kind of like western
inspired i love that [ __ ] yeah that's
great
but
don't try to make it like pop music or
don't try to make it like hip-hop or
don't it's i don't know you're just like
making it worse than all i don't know
i don't know i don't love it all right
jen i think we ought to shut it down
all right let's get oh michael says next
movie you guys should watch is bad
lieutenant you know what i mean batman
okay bad lieutenant i haven't seen it it
was actually in the poll yeah
last week or the week before but it
didn't win
but it's on
to be or something like that so it's
it's in there so we'll probably like do
it
pretty soon like in the next month or so
because i do actually want to rewatch it
i haven't seen in a long time all right
so
we're starving yeah
uh all we've had today is some baba
canoes yeah from those eggplants that
we've been using back here
all those million eggplants
eggplant uh so yeah so we're gonna go
get some food hopefully you guys do the
same or do whatever it is you're doing
where whatever time it is where you are
so thank you for dropping by and hanging
out with us on this friday night
hopefully you have a lovely weekend up
ahead we will see you guys
on sunday at 6 p.m eastern standard time
we'll be talking about another movie
probably the first godfather because
louis sent us the um
the godfather trilogy oh i wanted to say
to you to uh thank you to miguel
for sending us a paypal
donation
uh so i wanted to make sure i got that
in but yeah so louis sent us all the
godfather movies so we're going to be
watching those over the weekend so we'll
probably talk about the first one on
sunday so hopefully we'll see you guys
then
and we'll see you guys on sunday
bye